Um 22 Uhr und eine Minute.].
Wunderschöne Named.
Ja, Named.
Frank, warum sitzt du auf dem Boden?
Na, ich hatte zumindest einen kleinen Hängemattenunfall. Das ist ein Kugel.
Das ist ein Kugel. 61, verzeihung. Ja, dann kann das ja nicht stimmen, was ich da erzähle. 61, verzeihung, Chaosradio 61 auf Fritz, schönen guten Abend. Heute reden wir über was, wo ich nur dumme Fragen stellen werde. Klar, ja, erzähl doch mal. Ist doch dein Job, oder?
Wir reden über die Sicherheit oder die Unsicherheit in Welflern Netzen, die Basoro überall gefunden haben.
Ah ja, im Studio Frank, Mats und Morix und... Der Multi von Krux. Heute heißt er Krux. Die haben immer irgendwie andere Namen. Leute, das ist eigentlich so, dass immer dieselben vier Leute hier sind. Die fressen bisweilen Kreide, damit sie schminken wie Mädchen, aber es sind eigentlich immer dieselben. Die geben sich da immer nur irgendwie komische andere Namen. Ja, Chaosradio 61, wir haben heute ein bisschen seltsame Musik, das habe ich mir sagen lassen. Moderiert ihr das doch mal an hier, weil ich nehme sowas nicht in den Mund.
Nein, das ist doch nicht seltsam, das ist doch einfach nur so, dass einige Leute hier immer der Meinung sind, dass Hacker nur Techno hören. Es gibt hier Leute, die sind der Meinung, dem ist nicht so.
Ja, dem ist nämlich tatsächlich nicht so, weil Hacker hören auch Slipknot mit No Life. Wenn da so eine rote Lampe leuchtet, dann heißt das, dass das Mikrofon an ist und alle hören was man sagt. Ich lasse jetzt eben die Platte noch zu Ende laufen, dann machen wir weiter. Jungs, was ist mit euch los? Warum hören Hacker denn nicht nur Techno? Ich dachte, die hören immer nur Techno.
Das ist ein weit verbreitetes Vorteil, aber zum Beispiel eine Demokoder-Ziele ist so wie Punkrock und Metal sehr weit verbreitet. Aber Hacker sind da, die durchmengen sich nicht wirklich.
Die durchmengen sich nicht wirklich. Klingt wie nicht incestuous, das ist schön. Sicherheit von Wavelanenetzen ist das Thema heute im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wollen wir nochmal bei Adam und Eva anfangen und Wavelanenetze erklären, Jungs?
Klar, kann man machen.
Gucken wir unterm Tisch hier, auch Frank auch, dieser Meinung ist Frank.
Ja, bei Wavelanenetzen handelt es sich eigentlich um eine mittlerweile ziemlich breit verbreitete Technik. Das nennt sich IEEE 802.11, das ist dieser Standard. Damit kann man zu Hause oder in irgendwelchen Betrieben Rechner miteinander vernetzen, ohne dass man Kabelwürmer hat. Man kann, wenn man auch die Möglichkeit gar nicht hat, Kabel zu verlegen, kann man einfach so ein Wavelanenetz bauen und hat keinen Stress und alles ist schön.
Woher weißt du, dass ich kein Werkzeug zu Hause habe?
Na, Wavelanen ist für Leute wie dich gemacht. Man kauft einfach so eine kleine Base Station, stellt die hin, schaltet die an, da hat man Netz in der ganzen Wohnung.
Sind da selbst installierende Echsen dabei?
Nö, einfach so ein Treiber irgendwie, das gängige Windows irgendwie, beherrscht das auch so mit dem Wavelanen. Also schaltet man einfach an und geht. Dann hat man alle seine Freunde und nicht-Freunde und Nachbarn auch mit ins Versorgte in der Umgebung.
Ist das ja mittlerweile zu einem einigermaßen akzeptablen Preis zu haben, oder ist das immer noch jenseits der 1000 Mark, wenn ich da ordentlich sage?
Na ja, also für 1000 Mark kriegst du eine Base Station und eine Karte. Das ist so ungefähr der Satz, den man auf der Straße bezahlt.
Wie teilt sich das auf? Was kostet die Karte? Was ist die Station?
Na die Karten kosten so irgendwie zwischen 3 und 400 Mark, manchmal ein bisschen teurer. Und die Station so irgendwas zwischen 6 und 700 Mark.
Karte und Karte kann ich aber auch vernetzen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, das ist dann sogar der Ad-Hoc-Modus.
Also ich könnte einfach meinen normalen stationären PC nehmen, den als Internetzugang nehmen und meinen Laptop durch die Wohnung schleppen und ihm beide eine Karte stecken.
Kommt aber nochmal teurer, weil du für die kleine PC-MC-RA-Karte nochmal einen adapter-brauchstehenden PC reinstecken kannst, damit du die PC-MC-RA-Karte be-
Das stimmt, das hätte man dann Milchmädchenrechnungen. Gut, wo fangen wir an? Fangen wir einfach damit an, dass ihr die Handys ausschaltet. Meins ist aus. Ist aus, ja, okay. Das heißt mobile. Nee, war auch gesinnes Handy.
Olga, das heißt mobile.
You've got to be handy with the mobiltelefon, ne? Äh, so, mobiltelefone aus und äh...
Habt ihr eigentlich keine Sprachregelungen bei diesem Sender?
Was?
Habt ihr keine Sprachregelungen bei diesem Sender?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine, so Handy irgendwie klingt irgendwie blöd, oder?
Ihr Handy klingt blöd, aber alle sagen's. Also, es ist ja Konsens. Oh ja, unser Kabel hat übrigens einen Wackelkontakt, wo die Musik drüber kommt. Wir haben nämlich nur ein Kabel.
Haben wir aus den Chaosräumen geklaut.
Genau. Und das ist nur... Kricks, lass das. Fass das einfach nicht an. Können wir uns jetzt vielleicht mal über Waveline Security unterhalten?
Wir können ja mal sagen, wo es alles angefangen hat.
Ja, bitte. Na wann vor allen Dingen? Ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her, oder?
So richtig aktiv hat es angefangen auf der C-Bild. Da sind wir mit unseren Sportgeräten, sprich Laptops, durch die Gegend gezogen, haben unsere Waveline-Karten drin gehabt, aufgeklappt und konnten uns vor offenen Netzen nicht mehr erraten. Das heißt, die Leute haben da einfach ihr gesamtes Netzwerk nach draußen gepustet. Und jeder, der irgendwie vorbeigelaufen ist und ein Notebook dabei gehabt hat, mit einer Kabel, konnte einfach mal gucken, was da so durch die Gegend fliegt. Und man muss dazu sagen, dass es theoretisch die Möglichkeit gibt, diese Netzwerke zuzumachen. Das heißt, dass es nicht jeder sofort, seht ihr, vorbeikommt. Man kann sie einmal verstecken und verschlüsseln. Das haben die irgendwie alle nicht gemacht. Also zumindest ziemlich viele. Also die, die wir gesehen haben, haben es zumindest nicht gemacht.
Siemens, hat Siemens das gemacht?
Zu welchem Stand waren die denn?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber wir sind ja nicht durch viele Hallen gekommen, das war das Donner. Wir sind ja in vielen Hallen immer lange, lange kleben geblieben.
Ach, gab es was interessantes, dass man kleben kann auf der CeBit? Ich dachte, auf der CeBit gibt es gar nichts interessantes mehr.
Na ja, in den Netzen schon.
Ja, da haben wir nämlich von so einer größeren europäischen Internet Service Providerfirma, haben wir da so ein Netzwerk entdeckt, die da so ziemlich alles falsch gemacht haben.
Ja, deswegen halt einfach anders, wie das Netz nicht versteckt haben. Das heißt, das war einfach offen.
Telekom, AOL, die Konkurrenz.
Konkurrenz nennt sich zweitgrößter europäischer Internet Provider. Na ja, die haben halt angefangen. Der erste Fehler war zum Beispiel, dass sie das Netz offen hatten. Zweiter Fehler war, dass sie das Netz Office genannt hatten, was die Sache doppelt interessant gemacht hat. Das gab in dieser Halle irgendwie sieben Netze und die Entscheidung fiel nicht wirklich schwer. Dann haben die halt nicht diesen WEP-Standard benutzt. Das erklären wir nachher nochmal. Das ist irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, einen Standard um diesen ganzen Verkehr, der da über die Luft fliegt, zu verschlüsseln bzw. zu verschleiern.
Und der dritte Fehler war gewesen, dass einer der Mitarbeiter aus dieser Firma einfach mal seine E-Mails abgeholt hat von seinem Server, der V3.
Man weiß ja auch noch, der Regionalmanager.
Das waren 10 Megabyte Mails und das war ursprünglich spannend, was ein Regionalmanager kriegt, Bewerbungsunterlagen von diversen Leuten, die da anfangen wollten.
Da war abgefahrenes Zeug drin, das ging über irgendwelche Geschäftsbilanzen vom Quartal und Bewerbungsunterlagen.
Und umsätze von Kursen.
Gib doch mal her.
Ja, da gab es einige Bedürftige, die da was abhelfen hatten. Dann haben wir uns mit den Leuten unterhalten von dieser größeren Firma.
Die waren ziemlich dankbar.
Die hatten großartig Versprechungen gemacht, die wollten uns noch einen kostenlosen FTP-Server hinstellen, den man benutzen kann, aus der Dankbarkeit. Hat sich dann irgendwie alles ziemlich schnell geerdet. Deswegen überlegen wir, ob wir mal sagen, wie die heißen.
Die Standard-Konfiguration auf der C-Bit war, dass die Firmen ihr Netz von zu Hause, ihr Firmennetz, hingewutet haben. Und sich für die Bequemlichkeit auf dem Stand, damit ihre Vertriebsmitarbeiter ihre Laptops benutzen können, das Corporate-Intranet auf eine Wave-Line-Dose raufgelegt haben. Da konnte man entsprechend weit gucken.
Das erste, was wir da gesehen haben, das war in der Nähe von IBM. Da haben wir uns dann so ein bisschen auf die Treppe gesetzt und ein bisschen geguckt, weil die erste Halle war ganz interessant. Irgendwann kamen halt von IBM irgendwelche Leute vom Standpersonal und haben halt ziemlich treffend bemerkt, als sie so in die Monitore geguckt haben, dass es sich um offene Wave-Lane handelt, was wir da gerade haben. Und dann fing einer halt zu erzählen, dass das Wave-Lane, was IBM dort hat, ja sicher sei. Die benutzen da 128-Bit-Verschlüsselungen. Und wenn man das allerdings knacken würde, wenn man da reinkriegen würde, dann würden Köpfe rollen, weil nämlich das gesamte IBM-Intranet mit dem Wave-Lane auf der C-Bit verbunden ist.
Vielen Dank für diesen Hinweis.
Sagen wir uns auch. 128 Bits sind schon einigermaßen sicher. Das kriegt man heutzutage nicht so leicht geknackt. Andererseits ist es halt auch nur durch Schlüssel geschützt, die man wissen muss, und dann kommt man ins Netzwerk rein. Und das Dumme an so einer großen Firma ist, dass die auch Mitarbeiter haben. Also da stehen echt Leute um die rum. Die wissen es zwar nicht, aber die haben irgendwie Computer, die sie wissen. Und wenn man sich dann da, wenn du einfach mal daneben stellst, neben so einem Mitarbeiter und denen irgendwie ein zwangloses Gespräch verwickelt, dann...
Laptops hin und her reicht. Größen- und Gewichtsvergleiche.
Oder so ganz klein niedlichen Laptop mit, glaub ich, so Z50. Boah, der ist aber süß.
Kommen wir dann ins Gespräch und darfst dich dann auch mal die Waveline-Konfiguration auf dem Windows-Rechner ansehen.
Oh, ist ja noch gar nicht zu Ende, aber jetzt haben wir die Mikros eingeschaltet. Chaosradio 61, Wavelan Security. Das ist unser Thema. Ihr wart auf der Cebit und habt Wavelan gemacht.
Ja, wir haben Wetter gefunden, eigentlich mehr als zwei.
Wo war man denn eben stehen geblieben? Bei IBM. Also die IBM Leute, die haben gesagt, da rollen also Köpfe, wenn ihr bei dem Ding reingeht.
Wir haben aber dann aus Angst vor den herumstreuenden IBM-Lern uns nur hingesetzt, mit Notbuch aufgeklappt und mal nachgeguckt. Dann haben sie schon böse geguckt und dann haben wir uns dann irgendwie aus dem Ding-Show-Effekt dann einfach mal schnellstens entfernt irgendwie zugeklappt, hektisch umgeguckt und sind weggerannt. Da hat man massiv Eindruck geschunden. Was nämlich aus dem Netzwerk so gefährlich ist für denjenigen, in das Netzwerk man eindringt, ist ja, dass man dort eine offizielle IP-Adresse von diesem Netzwerk abbekommt. Das heißt, man gehört einfach zu diesem Firmenetzwerk und wenn man jetzt irgendwie schon immer mal den CIA scannen wollte oder eine Attacke gegen das FBI fahren oder was einem so einfällt, dann fällt man da nicht weiter auf. Man sieht so aus, als ob man aus dieser Firma kommt, in deren Werfen und Netz man sich gerade befindet und kann da massiv Ärger anrichten. Das ist irgendwie so einer der Gründe, warum man darauf achten sollte, dass man keine fremden Leute in sein Werfennetz lässt.
Man kann es einfach nicht nachvollziehen, was da überhaupt passiert ist. Schon ziemlich heikel.
Ist ziemlich dumm.
Dass man da auch gleich mit IP und Gateways beworfen wird und dann ein breitbandiges Internet hat, also...
Ja, aber dazu ist es doch eigentlich da, oder nicht?
Na ja, für die Angestellten dieser Firma sicherlich. Ich meine, ich hab mich auch gefreut, dass ich da die Möglichkeit hatte, mal Internet zu haben, aber...
Also normalerweise muss man auch nicht allen Leuten gleich erzählen, wie man jetzt raus ins Internet kommt. Das reicht ja halt irgendwie, wenn das bei dem Rechner lokal konfiguriert wird, dass er weiß, über welchen Rechner er ins Internet kommt, aber die erzählen dann das irgendwie ganz fleißig. Die ACP ist nämlich so ein Protokoll, da fragt man einfach mal, wie ist meine IP-Adresse, wie ist mein Router, wie ist die Netzmaske. Der sagt das dann und dann ist man irgendwie vollständig drin. Das kann man sich auch aus sich auch kneifen, wenn man die Rechner richtig konfiguriert hat. Aber die haben das Bescheid gesagt und dann hatten die ja natürlich, wenn man von innen kam, hat die Firewall auch nichts genutzt. Also nach außen sind ja irgendwie alle furchtbar sicher, dass man von außen irgendeine Connection aufgemacht werden soll. Dann gucken die schon ganz genau nach, welcher Rechner mit da adressiert, welcher Port. Aber wenn das von drinnen passiert, dann denken die sich, ja wird schon alles seine Richtigkeit haben. Und dann kommt man meistens von drinnen auch überall hin nach draußen und kann massiv Schaden anrichten.
Das ist halt das Problem. Die sichern das Netz nach außen hin massiv ab, dass gar nichts passieren kann und rechnen überhaupt nicht damit, dass von innen irgendwas passieren kann, dass es innen so eine krasse Sicherheitslücke gibt, wie so ein Waveline-Net.
So eine Firewall spiegelt einem eine furchtbare Sicherheit vor. Man geht in den Laden und sagt, ich muss mein Netzwerk sicher machen und dann klar, Sicherheits-Firewall-Paket hier gleich installieren. Dann ist es da und dann kauft dann noch ein verpeilter Systemadministrator so eine Base Station, stellt die da einfach mal hin, möglichst noch in die Firewall rein und macht damit sein Netz von innen offen.
Ja, so hört sich das an, wenn Musik von digitalen Quellen gespielt wird. Chaosradio 61, Waveline Security, aber erstmal die Dinge, die sonst noch in der Welt passiert sind.
Wenn, dann Fritz.
Halb zwei elf.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Halb elf.
Das Wetter nachts kann es vereinzelt regnen. Die Temperaturen sind auf zwölf bis acht Grad. Morgen wird es wolkenreich, dabei bilden sich Schauer, örtlich auch Gewitter. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 17 und 21 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gesine Kühne.
Die Entschädigung der ehemaligen NS-Zwangsarbeiter kann begonnen werden. Der Bundestag stellte die erforderliche Rechtssicherheit für deutsche Unternehmen fest. Das heißt, den Firmen drohen in den USA keine Klagen von Betroffenen. Für die Entschädigung stehen insgesamt zehn Milliarden Mark zur Verfügung. Die Regierung in Potsdam stellt in diesem Jahr 30 Millionen Mark für das Projekt Tolerantes Brandenburg bereit. Das Geld soll für Jugendarbeit und das Aktionsprogramm gegen Neonazis ausgegeben werden. Außerdem soll es ab dem kommenden Schuljahr verbindliche Lehrpläne zum Thema Rechtsextremismus geben. In Paris ist der frühere französische Außenminister du Marvigen bestechlichkeit zu sechs Monaten Haft verurteilt worden. Er musste sich im Zusammenhang mit der Schmiergeld-Affäre um den Ölkonzern 11 Agitänen verantworten. Sachsens Ministerpräsident Biedenkopf muss rund zu 120.000 Mark an die Landeskasse zurückzahlen. Ihm wurde vorgeworfen, das Landespersonal in seiner Villa sowie den Dienstwagen privat genutzt zu haben. Der Europäische Fußballverband UEFA hat die Stadionsperre gegen Galatasaray Istanbul aufgehoben. Sie war nach den Ausschreitungen der Zuschauer beim Champions-League-Spiel gegen Real Madrid Anfang April verhängt worden. Und zum Stadtverkehr Berlin A100-Lichtenberg Richtung Wilmersdorf. Vorsperrung zwischen Tempelhof und Buschkuk Allee wegen Bauarbeiten von 21 bis 4 Uhr.
Vielen Dank, Sie sind kühne. 22.32 Uhr.
Triss und Levi's Angel in Jeans Music holen Outkast nach Berlin. Its E-Werk am Donnerstag. Und die Vorband habt ihr bestimmt.
Das sind Pillskills.
Vom aktuellen Fritz Berlin macht Schule Hip-Hop-Sender. Outkast, Donnerstag im E-Werk Berlin. Karten gibt's nirgendswo zu kaufen.
Sondern nur zu gewinnen.
Im Levi's flagship Store an der Berliner Gedächtniskirche. Und diese Woche in eurem Rad.
So, was soll ich sagen, was das ist?
Regensburger Alkoholiker Puck kann gerade im Chat.
Regensburger Alkoholiker Puck, nicht Punk, Puck, Puck.
Meinst du zumindest Artwort?
Punk, ich glaub das wär Puck, Punk. Wieso, wieso war das? Aus, steht hier nicht?
Regensburg.
Regensburg, genau, Alkoholiker aus Regensburg von 1992 erschienen auf Hawk. Chaosradio 61 auf Fritz, schönen guten Abend, wir haben 5, 5, 11 und wollen über Waveline Security reden bzw. den Spaß, den man mit ungesicherten Waveline netzten hat. Und wir waren immer noch auf der Cebit, ne?
Wir waren immer noch auf der Cebit und haben da lustige Sachen erlebt.
Erzähl doch mal die lustigen Sachen und deute nicht nur an.
Genau, habt ihr auch geschnifft?
Was Sniffing ist?
Was Sniffing ist.
Eine ganz alte Sache. Genau.
Ich erzähl's einfach mal. Man nimmt einfach eine Ethernet-Karte und man kann diese Ethernet-Karten auch dazu überreden, dass sie einem komplett, jeden Traffic, der auf diesem Netz ist, also alles, was an Datenpaketen hin und her geht, direkt auf dem Rechner anzeigt, beziehungsweise denen einfach alles direkt in den Rechner reinholt. Das heißt, man bekommt nicht nur die Pakete, die für den Rechner, an dem man selber arbeitet, gedacht sind, wie es eigentlich normal ist bei TCPIP oder anderen Netzwerkprotokollen, sondern man bekommt tatsächlich alle Pakete und kann auch alles sehen, was andere Leute auf diesem Netzwerk tun. Das ist natürlich bei Firmenetzten besonders interessant. Der Fachbegriff dafür lautet Promiscuous Mode. Das heißt, die Gefahr, die da besteht, ist natürlich offensichtlich. Man kann alles mitlesen, was an unverschönen Protokollen da langkommt, also Passworte, E-Mails, Lock-In-Sessions, Webverkehr und so weiter und so fort. Also einmal alles sozusagen.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass wenn man unverschöne Protokolle mitgesnifft hat, da kommt ja auch so Diverser Traffic, dass sich Leute zum Beispiel bei ihrem Pop3 Server die Mails abholen. Pop3, so bekannter Standard. Man ruft den Server an, sagt ihm, mein Name ist, mein Passwort ist, gibt mir mal meine sämtliche Post. Und da das alles mit Klartext verschlüsselt ist, bekommt man halt den Usernamen und das Passwort irgendwie mal auf seinen Computer, wie schön groß, wie so ein Hackerfilm auf dem Bildschirm.
Echt, so richtig arm? Ja, so richtig peinlich, so in groß so.
Ja, ja, richtig peinlich. Man schenkt sich zwei Umstaben drauf. Genau. Und das Schöne ist, dass diese Passwörter meistens nicht nur einmal blau um die Post abzuholen, sondern dass die auch dazu nützlich sind, sich auf diesem Rechner so generell auch eine Shell aufzumachen, also sich da irgendwie per Tenant einzuloggen, weil die Passwörter meistens halt nicht unterschiedlich sind für POP3 und Telnet. Und wenn man da mal eine Shell hat, dann kann man natürlich irgendwie noch mehr Blödsinn machen, als einfach nur die Mails abholen. Da kann man wirklich mal die gesamten Dateien da durchgucken, was man da nicht für lustige Berichte findet. So bei größeren Firmen, das ist immer sehr spannend. Und gerade heutzutage im Zeitalter, wo Informationen und Kriege entscheiden können, sollte sich eigentlich jeder bewusst sein, wie nützlich ist es, seine eigenen Informationen irgendwie zu schützen.
Also IBM hatten wir ja schon ab da noch irgendwelchen gefunden, also noch irgendwelche großen Firmen, die ja angeblich ganz viele Leute beschäftigen für viel Geld.
Naja, nicht auf der CeBit, aber...
Mit der CeBit fing es ja alles an. Es war so das erste Aha-Erlebnis, da hat man erstmal gesehen, ups.
Es ist Dummheit, es ist massiv verbreitet, so ein Ort bei deutschen Systemen.
Was man überdenken muss, ist, dass diese Firmen auch sogenannte Experten beschäftigen. Die in den Medien zu Worten kommen und kluge Reden halten. Die vergessen in der Regel auch die simpelsten Sachen. Es ist nicht so, dass man besonders befähigt sein müsste. Man muss einfach nur zwei Buttons mehr anklicken beim Einrichten der Basisstation. Vielleicht noch mal kurz ein Wort dazu, wie WaveLand funktioniert. Es gibt sogenannte Basisstationen, auch auf Englisch Space Station genannt. Die sind sozusagen der zentrale Knotenpunkt, an dem sich die ganzen WaveLand-Karten anmelden. Darüber wird dann die Verbindung zum eigentlichen normalen Netz hergestellt. In der Regel hängt so eine Basisstation am normalen Ethernet dran. Ethernet ist das Netzwerk, das man benutzt, um Computer miteinander zu vernetzen. Man kann es sich so vorstellen wie eine Funkverlängerung für das Ethernet. Das heißt, dass man darüber ganz normal arbeiten kann. Die Bandbreite, die man da hat, ist nicht so groß wie im normalen Ethernet. Also nominal sind es 11 Megabit im Vergleich zu 100 Megabit, was man heutzutage im normalen Fass Ethernet hat. Realistisch bekommt man ungefähr zwischen 6 und 7 Megabit dadurch. Das heißt, es reicht nicht, wenn man große Downloads machen will, aber es reicht irgendwie, um normal im Netz zu arbeiten.
Genau, also 11 Megabit ist irgendwie hin und zurück. Das heißt, dass man einen nominalen Durchsatz wirklich nur 5, 5 Megabit hat.
Das ist mehr als ich jetzt zu Hause habe. Ja gut, also was brauche ich ein Netzwerk zu Hause, wenn raus nur maximal ISDN geht?
Um deine Filme von einem Rechner auf den anderen zu ziehen.
Super, hey, ich habe eine sehr kleine Wohnung.
Wie, da gehst du einfach rüber?
Ich ziehe einfach ein Kabel vom Videorekorder ins Schlafzimmer.
Du bist ja ein Spießer.
Was mir noch am Base Station lustig ist, dass sie zum Teil auch direkt an die Telefonhose angeschlossen werden können und als Modem fungieren. Das heißt, jemand kauft sich dieses Teil, steckt es zu Hause in die Telefondose und es macht dann irgendwie den ganzen Teil ab für dich. Und du hast einfach mal ganz einfach Internet in der ganzen Wohnung. Und weil die meisten Leute keinen Flatrate haben, wird es irgendwie so automatisch, wenn irgendjemand mal ein Paket ins Internet schicken möchte, wird Internet eingeschaltet. Und das ist ganz nützlich, wenn man draußen steht, dann kann man natürlich auch vor der Tür von demjenigen da das Internet einschalten und irgendwie seine Online-Kosten irgendwie mal ins Astronomische. Es reicht irgendwie, wenn man alle 10 Minuten da irgendwie mal ein Paket durchschickt und wählt sich immer wieder ein und wird richtig teuer. Deswegen sollte noch halb mein Wender vielleicht schauen, ob sie ihre Base station...
So jetzt mal davon abgesehen, mal davon abgesehen, dass die Leute bei EBM auf der CeBIT gesagt haben, ja wenn ihr hier in unser offenes Welflarnetz reingeht, dann rollen Köpfe. Wie reagieren die denn sonst denn oder hin? Ich mein, das ist doch so super peinlich irgendwie. Also ihr geht da hin und sagt, guten Tag, ich heiße Schneider und bei Ihnen ist ja alles am Arsch. Was machen die, dann schämen die sich wenigstens?
Ja es hängt davon ab, mit wem man da redet. Also bei einer großen Firma hier in Berlin, was ich von meinen Namen nennen. Also es handelt sich dabei um die allseits beliebte und bekannte Firma Dan La Benz. Die Biss, genau. Die hatten am Potsdamer Platz ein offenes Waveline, was irgendwie doch eher ziemlich interessant war. Und wir haben dann, nachdem wir uns angeguckt hatten, entschieden, naja, okay, dann tun wir ihnen mal den Gefallen und rufen sie mal an und versuchen mal da zu kommunizieren, dass es da ein Problem gibt. Und der Zeitraum zwischen, wir haben intensiv versucht, ihnen das Problem zu kommunizieren und das Problem wurde tatsächlich behoben bei drei Wochen oder sowas, solange haben sie tatsächlich gebraucht, dass da den Verantwortlichen zu finden, der dann wiederum doch nicht verantwortlich war und dann haben sie einen anderen Verantwortlichen gefunden. Und naja, dann hat es noch mal eineinhalb Wochen gedauert, bis es irgendwie einen Termin gab, wo sie dann Zeit für uns hatten und wir ihnen das dann erzählen konnten. Dann hat es noch mal zwei Tage gedauert, bis wir sie abgeschaltet haben. Also es war...
Das heißt, zum Salzufer in Berlin brauche ich mich jetzt nicht mehr zu begeben, ja? Ne, es war am Potsdamer Platz. Ach, das ist aber schick. Am Potsdamer Platz im Kaffee sitzen und irgendwie Internet haben.
Das war einigermaßen schwach. Also insofern bis ins Kaffee jetzt nicht gereicht leider doch.
Ne, es war nicht schwach, sondern es war echt, es war ziemlich stark, aber es waren ziemlich schmalere Streifen. Das heißt, meistens stehen die Base Stations irgendwo und das Signal wird dann doch von Stahlkonstruktionen oder so aufgehalten, aber wenn irgendwie eine dicke Glasfront ist, dann gibt es da meistens so, na, von so einem zentralen Punkt aus, Strahlensätze, gibt es da so Streifen, die da voll bestrahlt werden und die muss man finden.
Aber das war da schon ganz okay. Was für eine... Das war kalt, was für Reichweiten war das denn? Das war so der erste schöne warme Tag.
Da war ein McDonalds in der Nähe, das war das wichtigste.
Was für Reichweiten hat es?
Abhängig von Witterungsverhältnissen, von wie die Gebäude da gebaut sind. Also Stahlbeton lässt das natürlich eher nicht so gut durch. Ja, Sichtkontakt, da kommt man schon echt weit. Also man hat auch festgestellt, dass bei der hohen Luftfeuchtigkeit irgendwie auch ein bisschen schwächer ist.
Was nennst du denn echt weit?
Na so 2, 3, 5 Meter, maximal. Also die normalen Reichweiten, die man so in Wohngebieten findet, ist so auf dem Bürgersteig davor und dann noch so bis zur Straßenmitte, wenn das irgendwie so eine kleine Base Station ist ohne extra Antenne, die halt sich irgendjemand in die Wohnung stellt. Aber bei Firmen und anderen Institutionen, erzähl mal später noch, haben wir durchaus irgendwie erheblich größere Reichweiten gefunden. Also das Problem ist, mit dem Netz zu finden, ist natürlich irgendwie, man wäre irgendwie nicht so mit seinem Laptop unter dem Arm da irgendwie durch die Gegend rennen zu müssen. Da rennt man doch zu häufig gegen die Herren und so. Es gibt aber zum Glück irgendwie so Ipaks, das sind so kleine Taschencomputer, für die es auch einen PC Card Slot gibt. Und da kann man auch so eine Welflingkarte reinstecken. Und dann hat man so ein etwas größer als Taschenrechner, großes Gerät mit, mit dem man irgendwie ganz bequem in der Tasche durch Berlin laufen kann. Und wenn die LEDs oben, also die kleinen Lampen oben auf der Welflingkarte angehen, dann weiß man, dass man ein Netz gefunden hat. Also so die statistische Häufigkeit von Netzen, wenn man in so Gegenden rumfährt, wo man viele Firmen vermutet und viele Start-ups vermutet, dann ist man so ungefähr bei einem Netz pro Stunde in Berlin, das man findet.
Das ist noch nicht schlecht. Also wenn die Lampen angehen, weiß ich, dass ich ein Netz gefunden habe. Und dann brauch ich noch die Keys.
Nee, wenn beide Lampen angehen, dann hast du ein Netz gefunden, für das du keinen Key brauchst.
Aha, und welchen Key brauche ich? Wofür finde ich den? Da rede ich wieder mit den Leuten.
Ja, einfach mal anrufen.
Was ist das wieder, dass die Frau eine Bescheid zu sagen?
Genau.
Holger, hier ist Chaosradio auf Fritz, die Sendung 61, die sich mit Waveline Security befasst. Also Sicherheit in Funknetzwerken, nicht? Oder so ähnlich? Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Was war das gerade? Socken? Haben wir gerade über Socken geredet?
Genau, über Socken. Wir haben festgestellt, dass eines der Probleme, die es so gibt, ist, dass diese Basetations sind halt unglaublich klein und brauchen auch nicht viel Strom. Und überall wo man Netz und ein bisschen Strom hat, kann man die Dinge halt hinhängen. Und das machen viele Mitarbeiter in Unternehmen auch ohne, dass da irgendjemand in der EDV von weiß oder so. Und das führt dann halt irgendwie dann dazu, dass die Leute total überrascht sind, dass sie Waveline haben. Nichts davon wissen, weil irgendjemand wollte halt sich mal ein bisschen Waveline machen, damit er auch noch in der Cafeteria chatten kann und hat sich dann eine Basestation installiert und fertig. Also die Dinger sind halt wie gesagt so billig, dass irgendwie jeder Chefarzt so ein Ding halt irgendwie mal einfach mal viel billig ordern kann, ohne dass er irgendwie nochmal seinen Oberen fragen muss.
Schön, dass du es ansprichst.
Da gab es so einen Spiegelartikel kürzlich.
Da gab es so einen Spiegelartikel kürzlich, ja.
Wo also eine kriminelle Jugendorganisation namens CCC drin erwähnt wurde.
Da waren auch einige ältere Leute aus dem CCC ganz sauer, dass sie irgendwie plötzlich hier kriminelle Jugendliche sein sollen. Und haben sowieso lange gearbeitet, irgendwie um Hacker Image aufzubauen.
Ich finde ja kriminelle Jugendorganisation klasse. Ich hätte auch gerne ein T-Shirt. CCC, kriminelle Jugendorganisation. Also ich finde das schön. Das ist aber organisierte Jugendkriminalität. Organisierte Jugendkriminalität ist aber irgendwie noch schöner.
Holger, wir machen für dich eins, wo drauf steht, ich bin ein organisierter Jugendkrimineller.
Das ist schön, danke.
Fein, haben wir das geklärt.
Also ihr wart beim Arzt.
Ja, wir waren beim Arzt. Wir waren bei diesem Spielreporter, dem wir da irgendwie von der Geschichte von Azebed erzählen wollten, weil...
Weil ihr mal wieder Geld braucht und eine Exklusivstory verkauft habt.
Was haben wir gekriegt? Ein Bier haben wir gekriegt. Richtig.
Na, immerhin.
Genau. Und der Reporter hat uns vorgeschlagen, wir sollten doch mal irgendwie in dieser Straße da, XY gibt es irgendwie so, doch diverse Start-ups, fahren wir mal runter und gucken, ob es da Netze gibt.
Da wollte ich mal live dabei sein.
Wir haben das schön vorbereitet für ihn, sind die Straße runtergefahren und...
Dann mach nichts.
Wir waren ein bisschen enttäuscht, aber dann haben wir die Straße in die andere Richtung gefahren und plötzlich blinkt, blinkt mitten auf der Straße. Viel Internet und ein ganz seltsamer Name. Da stand irgendwie plötzlich Meoklinik Wavelan.
Der Wavelan-Doktor.
Ja, wir haben uns irgendwie nichts dabei gebracht. Meoklinik, was ist das? Haben irgendwie so einen Bekannten angerufen, so unser Gehirn. Was könnte ein Meoklinik sein da irgendwie in der Straße da? Und fiel die Kinnlade runter und sagte, das ist die teuerste Privatklinik in Berlin, die es da so gibt. So einmal die Lounge und alles super toll. Da haben wir uns dann einfach mal am nächsten Tag mit dem Spiegelreporter verabredet und wollten uns das angucken. Dann ging es nicht und war ein bisschen dumm. Wir sind dann in den Druck gekommen worden und klag, was war das Wetter gewesen? Spät abends war dann viel Luftfeuchtigkeit, hat geregnet und so. Da haben wir das nicht mehr gefunden und waren schon völlig enttäuscht. Haben gemeint, vielleicht haben sie es abends abgeschaltet. Haben uns den nächsten Tag nochmal verabredet und da war es wieder, weil da war sonnig. Genau. Und da war auf der Straße wenig Empfang. Also ich möchte mich unbedingt noch mal bei dem Haus der russischen Kulturen bedanken, weil das ist direkt daneben und da sind wir dann mal an die oberste Etage gefahren und da war...
Ein Schicksal, da waren wir dann ganz alleine und hatten Ruhe und konnten uns das Netzwerk einfach mal ansehen.
Ja, pack doch mal aus. Wie geht es Eberhard Diebken? Da glaube ich aber doch.
Es ging ja darum eben zu zeigen, dass wir da Möglichkeiten haben, uns das Netzwerk anzusehen, auch zu sagen, was sie da für Hardware im Stehen haben, was da für Betriebssysteme laufen.
Ja, wobei gerade bei so einer Klinik wird es dann ja auch echt ein bisschen gefährlich.
Was ist gefährlich ist, dass es einfach mal ohne Unverschämtheit...
Ja, davon mal abgesehen, dass es so eine ärztliche Schweigepflicht gibt, die da gebrochen wird. Ich meine, den Schabernack, den du von deiner Seite aus machen müsstest, ist ja auch wesentlich heftiger. Insulingaben an...
Wenn man erstmal drin ist, dann hat man eigentlich gewonnen. Weil meistens gibt es ja in so einem Firmennetzwerk ziemlich spannende Dinge. So ein Drucker, man denkt sich nicht dafür bei, aber so ein Drucker ist auch ins Netzwerk angeschlossen. Wenn man dann bei einem gewissen Drucker mal zu sagen, wir brauchen dringend 1000 schwarze Seiten, dann macht der 1000 schwarze Seiten, weil er denkt, du gehörst zum Netzwerk und du darfst es.
Das krasseste ist halt einfach die Tatsache, dass da Patientendaten durch die Luft fliegen und zwar vollkommen ungeschützt. Also ich meine, wir kommen später auch nochmal auf dieses Thema Sicherheit mit Web zu sprechen, aber selbst das wird auch nicht ausreichen.
Was dann halt wirklich erschütternd war, war, dass es nicht nur die Meoklinik war, die tatsächlich dieses offene Netz hatte, sondern halt noch viel mehr Krankenhäuser in Berlin. Also es war tatsächlich so, dass wir dann ausgehend von diesem Erlebnis losgefahren sind und uns so mehr oder minder alle Krankenhäuser angeguckt haben und die wir uns irgendwie erinnern konnten, dass wir so sind und haben in erstaunlich vielen dieser Krankenhäuser tatsächlich auf einer Wechselnetze gefunden.
Habt ihr denen das wenigstens gesagt oder?
Naja, natürlich.
Naja, das ging halt so weit, dass wir da dann schon mit höheren Leuten gesprochen haben, die sich daran gekümmert haben, dass das abgeschaltet wird.
Also in einem Krankenhaus war es so, dass wir Experimenter haben, um zu sehen, wie die so reagieren, halt direkt hingefahren sind, haben gesagt, wir waren mit dem Datenschutzbeauftragten reden, den vorher kurz angerufen und dann ist er mit uns dann tatsächlich über das Klinikgelände gezogen, weil er wusste nichts von dem Waveline und irgendwie sein EDV wusste auch nichts von dem Waveline und es war aber schön und stark und groß und ging irgendwie bis weit auf den Bürgersteig und und hieß Krankenhausname unterstrich Secure. Dann haben wir tatsächlich, also dann haben wir da eine Weile rumgesucht auf dem Gelände und haben tatsächlich irgendwie dieses Netz gefunden, also diese Base, die wir schon gefunden haben, die hing in so einer Besenkammer in so einem Flur, aber mit zwei deutlich sichtbaren Antennen. Und die Leute auf dieser Station, die waren vollständig überrascht. Und irgendwann haben sie dann jemanden aufgetrieben, der sich daran erinnerte, ja, vor zwei Jahren hat der Professor sowieso da was so gemacht mit so Penn-Computer, also flache Computer, die keine Tastatur haben. Und irgendwie dafür brauchte er irgendwie dieses Wäschlending, aber es funktionierte nie so richtig. Und naja, dann ist es irgendwie vergessen gegangen. Nein. Und dann haben sie es halt einfach vergessen. Zwei Jahre lang. Zwei Jahre lang. Und dann haben wir das dann zusammen mit dem örtlichen Datenschutzbeauftragten unter den doch irgendwie ziemlich rosa blau angelaufenen Gesichtern der EDV, die ziemlich planiert waren, das Ding da außer Betrieb genommen. Und naja, der nächste Schritt war dann halt, dass wir gesagt haben, okay, das kann nicht so weitergehen, dass wir jetzt jedes Krankenhaus einzeln anfangen. Und sind dann halt losgegangen, um da mal mit dem Datenschutzbeauftragten zu reden, das wir getan haben. Und haben auch mit dem Krankenhausverband geredet, die dann halt auch entsprechend die Nachrichten an die Krankenhäuser kommuniziert haben, und zwar nachdrücklich. Also wir denken, dass es mittlerweile bald den Po um sein sollte, das Problem.
Chaosradio, 61 um 23 Uhr, eine Minute auf Fritz, Waveline Security, unser Thema. Wie fliegen wir an dieser Stelle zumindest am frühen Morgen hier bei den Radio-Fritzen immer zu sagen?
Rock'n'Roll! Da macht sie mal mit dem Spaß.
Hier ist Chaosradio 61, Waveline Security. Sag mal, kann es sein, dass Hacker nicht nur Techno hören?
Na, ich hab Gerüchte gehört, dass die so ist. Ich hab aber gerade bemerkt, dass so wie im Chat die Leute aufgewacht sind. Also es scheint nicht Chaosradio Leute, die wollen draußen was lernen. Hier wird nicht gechillt.
Chillen kann nur, wenn ihr tot seid.
Alle wieder wach.
Wo war man schon bei Krankenhäusern?
Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Datenschutzbeauftragten. Was hatten die? Ihr seid irgendwann zum Datenschutzbeauftragten in Berlin gegangen oder was?
Ja, ja.
Und habt gesagt, hier ist was nicht in Ordnung. Was hat Neda gesagt?
Naja, um noch mal ganz kurz auf Krankenhaus zurückzukommen, das gab da auch ein Krankenhaus, hier möchten wir auch ganz herzlich gratulieren. Die haben es also geschafft, in einem Krankenhaus 31 Access Points aufzustellen, die alle frei zugänglich waren.
Welches war das? Ich mein, jetzt kann man ja nichts mehr machen. Da ist es ja jetzt egal.
Man konnte sich ganz gemütlich ins Krankenhauscafé setzen und...
Man konnte sich überall hinsetzen im Krankenhaus...
.Café und Kuchen.
Gab lecker Kuchen, da auch mal Danke an die Damen da.
Habt ihr denn auch wenigstens irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gefunden, Kaffee und Kuchen irgendwie in einer internen Abrechnung nicht bezahlen zu müssen? Das ist ärgerlich. Okay, der Datenschutzbeauftragte hat es wahrscheinlich auch zum ersten Mal in seinem Leben gehört, als ihr ihm das erzählt habt, oder?
Ja, der war ziemlich überrascht. Na ja, wir hatten da einen Termin bekommen und haben dann da mit drei Leuten vom Datenschutz zusammengesessen. Das waren auch Informatiker gewesen, die wussten also auch so ungefähr, worum es geht. Von WaveLand haben sie auch schon mal gehört. Und denen haben wir die ganze Story einfach mal erzählt und die waren ganz was Neues gewesen. Die konnten das erst gar nicht glauben und haben denen gesagt, was man alles so gesehen hat und so weiter und haben denen gesagt, dass die sich vielleicht auch einfach mal auf den Weg machen sollten, sich das angucken. Eigentlich wollten wir den Tag auch noch mal zusammen in so ein Krankenhaus fahren, aber das haben wir dann noch nicht gemacht. Na ja, dann hat man erst eine Weile darüber geredet, was denn so eine WaveLand-Karten kosten und so weiter.
Oh, das ist aber interessant. Ja, ist es. Wollen Sie wissen, was man damit machen kann?
Sie haben sogar einen Laptop, wo Sie die reinstecken könnten. Aber der war gerade mit dem Chef von den Datenschützern da im Urlaub gewesen. Einen Laptop haben Sie gehabt.
Einen. Und den nimmt der Chef in den Urlaub mit.
Jaja, man muss halt da arbeiten.
Jetzt fahren also die gelben Postautos mit der Antenne auf dem Dach, die haben jetzt doch alle noch WaveLand-Karten irgendwie.
Na ja, das wollte ich nicht. Weil als dann irgendwie anfingen, was nimmt man dann am besten für eine Karte und was soll man dann am besten kaufen, dann wurde halt irgendwie gesagt, die von Lewis sind die Karten, die sind halt recht gängig und die sind auch bezahlbar. Ja, was kosten die denn? Na ja, so um die 400 Mark. Gut, hat er sich aufgeschrieben, 400 Mark, gibt es da auch was billigeres? Verkauft man sich die denn am besten? Und die haben halt gesehen, dass wir so ein bisschen komisch geguckt haben und meinten halt, dass es schon irgendwie, es gibt Haushaltssperre und die müssten also schon gucken, da auf jede Mark achten, das umdrehen und schon das billigste, was wir denn so kriegen.
Das machen sie mit Bankvorstandsvorsitzenden ja auch, wenn sie so was billigst so was kriegen.
Tja, das ist der Berliner Datenschutz.
Ja, also quasi nicht vorhanden, oder? Sie legen sich ja ins Zeug. Also ich hatte auch mal den Berliner Datenschützer zu Gast und der legt sich ja schon ins Zeug irgendwie.
Wenn er das weiß, hat er was gemacht, wenn er davon was weiß. Aber von alleine kommen die halt nicht darauf. Die haben sich halt an die entsprechenden Stellen gewandt, die dann daraufhin über diese bundesweiten Verteiler an alle Krankenhäuser diese Meldungen rausgegeben haben, damit die alle da mal ihre Konfiguration überprüfen. Das hat doch gewirkt, das war ganz okay.
Aber wenn die das selbst nicht wissen, verlassen die sich eigentlich auf euch? Denken die sich, naja, früher oder später wird also eine kriminelle Jugend, ne, was wird das, kriminelle Jugendliche werden bei mir auftauchen und sagen, naja, so ist richtig, so ist falsch?
Ja, die haben halt schon gesagt, dass sie eigentlich diejenigen wären, die uns eigentlich anzeigen müssten. Haben aber auch gleich dahinter noch gesagt, dass sie ja schön blöd wären, wenn sie das tun.
Ja, dann wart ihr wahrscheinlich das letzte Mal da.
Wir haben ja da auch, ich meine, ja klar, ich meine, das wäre ja absoluter Schwachsinn, wir wollen ja da den Leuten einfach das erzählen, damit diese ganzen privaten Daten, gerade in Krankenhäusern, äußerst sensible Daten, dass sie einfach geschützt sind.
Und wir tun dir da nichts Böses mit.
Zum Glück machen wir hier kein Fernsehen, sonst hätte man das Grinsen gesehen.
Also was an diesen Krankenhäusern so spannend ist, dass ja diese Waveline Netze so normalerweise nur dahin gebaut werden, also außer diesem Krankenhaus mit den 31 Playstations, dass sie dahin gebaut werden, wo es irgendwie schnell gehen muss, so in einer Intensivstation, wo irgendwie der Arzt angerannt kommt, Laptop hinknallt und wie schnell eingeben und Krankenakte schreiben, dass man später Geld verdienen kann. Und genau das sind ja auch die sensiblen Bereiche, wo die Leute wirklich hilflos sind. Wenn die in die Intensivstation kommen, ist da mit denen irgendwie meistens was passiert, Unfall oder so, und dann liegen die da rum. Und dann sollte man eigentlich meinen, dass der Arzt dafür sorgt, dass über den Patienten nichts irgendwie nach draußen kommt. Also Schweigepflicht und...
Ja, nur wie soll er das machen, wenn ein schwachsinniger Adminstatist noch nicht mal schaffen, so ein Ding irgendwie sicher zu machen?
Ja, vielleicht sollte sich so ein Arzt wie man selber überlegen, was da passiert. Ich meine, meistens ist dieses Problem...
Das ist ja nicht der Job des Arztes. Also gerade Krankenhausärzte sind ja größtenteils wirklich arme Schweine. Also das meine ich jetzt von der Belastung her und von der Bezahlung her. Du kannst ja nicht von denen auch noch erwarten, dass die jetzt sich überlegen, ob dieses Funknetz, was sie da im Krankenhaus haben, denn sicher ist nach außen.
Ja, aber sie benutzen einfach mal die Technik. Sie nehmen sie einfach und benutzen sie ohne sich darüber zu informieren.
Ja klar, es werden ja Leute dafür bezahlt, diese Technik funktionierbar zu machen oder funktionierend beziehungsweise zuzumachen oder sicher zu machen.
Na vielleicht ist das Problem bewusst dann einfach nicht geschafft, weil die meisten Leute denken, was ich irgendwie mit meinen Mitteln nicht irgendwie mir angucken kann, das können wahrscheinlich andere auch nicht. Und da ist dann irgendwie der Hörderehorizont auf, wenn die hören, wie Funktechnik und Funk kann ja eh keiner abfangen.
Was ich mir sicher vorzuwerfen ist, dass sie noch nicht mal gefragt haben. Hallo, Viertel nach 11, hier hat Fritz Chaosradio 61. Wir reden schon seit einer guten Stunde über Sicherheit im Funknetz und Waveline Security. Haben wir schon so einiges gehört, dass Firmen wie EBM, Firmen wie Mercedes-Benz, wenn sie in irgendeiner Form öffentlich auftreten und da ihre Funknetze laufen haben, sich einen Teufel drum scheren, diese ganzen Sachen sicher zu machen. Zumindest so sicher zu machen, dass jetzt nicht irgendwer, der mit einem kleinen Laptop durch die Gegend läuft, sich einfach auf dieses Funknetz oder in dieses Funknetz einklinken kann und machen kann, was er will in diesem Funknetz. Noch schlimmer ist es in Berliner Krankenhäuser offensichtlich gewesen, denn in Berliner Krankenhäusern, da konnte man sogar in sensible Patientendaten ran. Und zwar, wenn ich euch richtig verstanden hab, ist das quasi alle Berliner Krankenhäuser, oder?
Naja, fast alle.
Ja, und da das hier eine Sendung ist, der Blue Moon auf Fritz, in der man anrufen kann unter dieser Nummer hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Da würde uns doch an dieser Stelle schon mal interessieren, ob ihr mit dem wenigen Wissen, das wir gerade vermittelt haben, schon genügend Angst bekommen habt, sodass ihr garantiert kein Funknetz so betreiben wollt. Die Nummer noch mal hier in Blumen.
Ja, wie groß ist eure Angst? Also meine wächst gerade stetig, stetig.
Ja, ich hab doch mal eine nette Adäktote. Also wir haben das im Chaos auch vor kurzem diskutiert im Vorbereitung der Sendung. Und da meinte dann jemand, der aus Erkner das Chaos besucht hatte, meinte dann, oh mein Gott, dieser Spiegelartikel ist in Erkner Stadtgespräche. Die meisten Leute trauen sich gar nicht mehr ins Krankenhaus. Und da haben wir uns gedacht, wenn wir so viel Panik geschütt haben, müssen wir das jetzt mal irgendwie relativieren.
Habt ihr aber mal geguckt, in Erkner ist alles in Ordnung oder was?
Ich fand nicht da.
Nee, das war doch zu weit. Man sollte davon ausgehen, dass da auch nicht besser gehandelt wird als hier.
Vielleicht haben die ja weniger Geld, vielleicht haben die gar keinen Strom. Wer hat diese Meldung an die Krankenhäuser rausgegeben? Also irgendwer hat seit ihr bundesweit eine Meldung an die Krankenhäuser rausgegeben. Ist davon auszugehen, dass die das abstellen oder?
Das ging halt über den Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Wir hatten selber dazu auch noch einen Text verfasst, die man netz einigermaßen sicher macht für die Ärzte.
So ein paar kleine Tipps für die Leute. Also grundlegende Sachen.
Ich meine, das ist eigentlich deren Job, ja.
Ich finde das einfach so klasse. Ich verdiene. Also ich meine, in so einer Privatklinik, da arbeiten wahrscheinlich auch nur Millionäre.
Na ja, in dieser Privatklinik kann man einigermaßen verstehen, was da passiert ist. Also da werden irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, die Ärzte geleast. Also da kommt irgendwie so ein reicher, irgendjemand mit Knieverletzung operieren lassen. Und dann gucken die kurz nach, ja, in welcher Berliner Universität haben wir denn da mal Arzt, der das kann. Ah, okay, der wird da für eine 1, 5 Stunden irgendwie mal geheiert. Kommt da vorbei, kriegt da sein Zimmer, was irgendwie so lauter Ärzte benutzt haben. Und da irgendwie großartig Verkabelung zu legen, ist irgendwie mal massiv schwer. Also kann er da irgendwie sein Notebook hinknallen, kriegt irgendwie eine IP-Adresse und fühlt sich irgendwie wie, als ob er in seiner eigenen Universität wäre und kann dann auch Netz haben.
Hui, wir haben den ersten Anrufer in dieser Sendung, warte mal. Guten Abend. Du heißt SQU.
Squelcher, gerade im Chat hier auch nebenbei.
Wie hieß du was? Ach so, ich hab nur SQU hier stehen.
Ah ja, das langt ja auch eigentlich.
Naja, aber es klingt komisch.
Ja, richtig.
Na, hast du Angst?
Ich habe ein bisschen geforscht, würde ich mal eher sagen.
Erzähl doch mal.
Ich war in Mannheim im Hauptbahnhof rumgestanden, in meinem Nordburg so, und irgendwie hat meine Welt angeblinkt.
Im Hauptbahnhof?
Im Hauptbahnhof von Mannheim. Ich wusste allerdings nicht, woher es kam, weil ich muss dann gleich wieder weg. Ich hab mal versucht, über mein Handy einen Swiftwunder zu laden, aber hat irgendwie nicht geklappt.
9600 baut? Ja, das ist irgendwie so übliches Problem, dass man immer nicht weiß, wo das herkommt. Und meistens haben die Wastestations einfach so hingeknallt, werden diese die Default-Namen, also diese Betriebswerk-Einstellungen, also ziemlich oft findet man Tsunami-Netze oder Elsa oder so. Genau, und das sagt gar nichts aus über die Firma. Also dann ist irgendwie, man kriegt so ungefähr raus, indem man irgendwie mal schaut, welche Rechner da so in der Gegend stehen. Die haben meistens irgendwie sprechende Namen. Oder man kann, wenn man zum Beispiel so einen iPad hat, kann man mal schauen, wie die Linkqualität sich verändert. Wenn man da und da hingeht, dann muss man wie Strahlensätze anwenden.
Hab ich schon getestet so ungefähr, weil auf der einen Seite war es stärker und da war nebendran zufällig eine Versicherung größer. Ich hatte da gerade nur irgendeinen billig kleinen drauf laufen.
So, liebe Hacker in Mannheim, tut uns einen Gefallen.
Sag uns doch mal, was das Film ist.
Kannst ja dann in den Chat kommen, wenn du sagst.
Skrelja, das war's schon?
Ich weiß nicht, also...
Wenn ihr jetzt nicht anfängt, Leute zu grüßen.
Natürlich kann ich jetzt in den ganzen Chat hier noch nebenbei grüßen.
Ja, dankeschön.
Das kannst du dir noch schreiben.
Ja, und was wollte ich sagen, genau. Gestern war ich bei meinem Chef und dem hab ich gemeint, dass wir in der Firma auch einen Wave-Lan brauchen.
Jetzt sag ich aber nicht, in welcher Firma ich arbeite. Das kriegen wir schon noch raus.
Bei EBM wird es nicht sein, die haben schon Wave-Lan.
Nicht wirklich.
Größere Firma, kleinere Firma, welche Brauchenschaft? Leicht, danke. Stille, Analyse.
Ja, dann danke ich an dieser Stelle einfach mal für deinen Anruf.
Alles da gut.
Tschau.
Ja, wenn ihr auch mit uns sprechen wollt, dann ist die Nummer hier.
Oder 31 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Wavelan und die Sicherheit oder Unsicherheit eben dieser Dinge. Wir haben ja eben gehört, wie schlimm es ist. Hallo Christian. Hallo. Hallo. Und, fürs ins Krankenhaus gehen?
Äh, nö, eigentlich nicht. Warum nicht? Nee, also ich hab vor kurzem erst so einen wunderschönen Funkrouter mal wieder bei einer Arztpraxis installiert, weil diese Ärzte ja offenbar zu viel Geld haben und auf Bequemlichkeitsgründen auch von zu Hause in ihre Praxen, die teilweise auch recht groß sind, sich einwählen wollen und da sie daheim mit dem Laptop überall rumrennen wollen, auch zu Hause eben diese Funkrouter installieren. Aber dummerweise eben relativ wenig Ahnung haben, wie man diese Teile halbwegs sicher kriegt.
Aus welcher Stadt bist denn du? Würzburg? Das ist so weit weg. Vielleicht gibt es ja Leute in Würzburg, die sich dafür interessieren. Hast du denn jetzt vielleicht nachdem du es gehört hast, irgendwie Ideen, dass du vielleicht noch was über ein Unternehmen kannst, so dass du da mal vorbei fährst und dem Bescheid sagst?
Ich habe das schon nach gutem Gewissen denen erklärt, nur die meisten meinen einfach, das bisschen an Bequemlichkeit ist ihnen wichtiger als dann die Sicherheit, weil sie gehen in den meisten Fällen einfach davon aus, dass ihnen niemand was tun würde.
Moment mal, die gehen davon aus, dass ihnen schon niemand was tun würde. Das ist genau dieselbe Blödsinn wie, ich verschlüssel meine Mails nicht, weil ich nichts zu verbergen habe, oder?
Richtig, das ist dieselbe Blödsinn. Aber man kann es den Leuten hundertmal lackieren und sie machen es dann einmal richtig und versuchen es dann einmal und wenn sie sehen, Hoppla es geht ein bisschen langsam oder Hoppla ich habe hier eine Unbequemlichkeit, dann tun sie es nicht, sondern wollen eben am besten sich irgendwo hin hocken und nach Möglichkeit alles funktioniert und nach Möglichkeit noch DVDs klotzen und gleichzeitig im Internet surfen und gleichzeitig noch arbeiten.
Das ist dieser übliche Trade-off zwischen Sicherheit und Bequemlichkeit. Muss aber nicht unbedingt sein, weil ja bei den Base Stations ist es halt einmal klicken und dann ist an und ich glaube, so viel Bandbreite kostet es einfach nicht so viel Bandbreite das verschlüsseln zu lassen. Hast du denn da das Netzwerk sicher gemacht?
Ich habe das sicher gemacht.
Schade.
Wie sicher denn?
Die haben es doch gar nicht gewollt. Warum machst du denn Sachen, die nicht dein Auftrag sind?
Ganz einfach deswegen, weil ich dummerweise auf euren Seiten gelegentlich rumklicke und mich genau dieses Thema doch sehr nachdenklich gestimmt hat.
Dann können wir nochmal www.ccc.de sagen.
Genau.
Christian, danke für deinen Anruf. Das Chaosradio Nummer 61, Waveline Security ist unser Thema. Und wenn ihr eure Erfahrungen mit Waveline oder wie nennt man das Gegenteil von Erfahrung?
Schlechter Erfahrung.
Danke schön. Ja, vielen Dank. Wenn ihr gute und schlechte Erfahrungen mit Funknetzen melden wollt, dann meldet euch bei uns, denn hier kann man anrufen in Blue Moon auf Fritz.
0331 für Potsdam 7097 110.
Das ist im übrigen Chaosradio 61 hier, Fritz. Diese Platte, die wir gerade hören, das ist eigentlich kriege ich nach jedem Chaosradio 10 Mails. Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Das ist alt. Ich glaube, es ist aus den 70ern, wenn ich mich täusche.
Das ist nicht meine Musik, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich muss mich nicht so anfassen.
Frank?
Von wann ist die Nummer? Also die Kraftwerk-Nummer?
Das ist 70er Jahre, oder? Ich bin ein bisschen älter, aber nicht so alt.
Genau.
Erzähl doch mal kurz. Das ist jetzt erstmal Kraftwerk in einem Remix von Anthony Rother. Und zwar nennt sich das Nummer ein Computerwelt. Und ja, ist ein Remix. Sind einige noch unterwegs heute.
Auf jeden Fall, wer es sich mal selber irgendwie besorgen will, Kraftwerk-Computerwelt sind die beiden Stichworte, die man braucht dafür.
Genau.
Und auch das, was immer um 22 Uhr als Sendungsopener läuft. So, jetzt hat es immer jeder gehört. Und wir telefonieren weiter, denn hier kann man anrufen. Die Nummer ist die hier. Oh, jetzt habe ich die schon weggemacht von der Maschine. Die Nummer lautet 0331 70 97 110. Und Michael hat sie gewählt. Hi Michael. Hallo Michael.
Ja, ich habe selber mehrere Netze aufgebaut, Wafeland für so Privathaushalte und auch für Anwaltskanzleien. Und da habe ich dann den Bericht gelesen und auch gemerkt, dass man da doch noch was ändern muss. Ja, erstmal die Grundkonfiguration, Base Station, ist klar, habe ich dann ziemlich schnell geändert und mir noch weiteres überlegt. Und da ist mir Pretty Good Privacy mit dem Netmodul eingefallen. Und das habe ich dann auch eingesetzt und das klappt eigentlich relativ gut. Das ist Pretty Good Privacy Net.
Meinst du das PGP-Net?
Ja, PGP-Net.
Also fährst du IPsec über deinen WLAN sozusagen?
Ja, das ist also von der Bandbreite klappert gut und Rechnerauslassung ist auch nicht so riesig.
Na ja, ein Drittel kriegt man so hin. So 300k solltest du pro Sekunde darüber werfen können, oder?
Ja gut, aber für Webklicken und über ihr ist das denn reich, das.
Da rechst du das allemal und das ist vor allen Dingen... Also dann ist es wirklich sicher, wenn du deinen Router auf jeden Fall so konfiguriert hast, dass es geht. Was hast du da auf der anderen Seite stehen?
Ein Linux-PC.
Ah, mit Freesworn.
Als seeliges Grinsen musste man denen dann zwar auch erst gut erklären, dass man da was machen muss, aber die waren dann doch einsichtig.
Ja, naja, das mit dem Freesworn ist so eine Sache, dass man den Kanal rein kompilen und der ganze Kram...
Ja, das hat auch etliche Stunden gedauert, bis es wirklich lief.
Hey, aber dafür hast du jetzt echt sicheres Welflager.
Mach doch mal eine Anleitung und packst du irgendwo ins Web, damit es jeder nachlesen kann.
Das ist echt die Menge an Anleitungen, kann man vielleicht ein paar URLs sagen, www.freesworn.org auf jeden Fall. Kannst du das mal buchstabieren? freeswan.org. Genau, Freesworn.
Jetzt hab ich das auch verstanden.
Genau, und dann gibt's natürlich noch, das war für die Linux-Fraktion und die anderen Leute noch sind natürlich die BSD-Leute. Und zwar ist da vornehmlich der Kame-Stack unterwegs, das sind so ein paar kranke Japaner, da kann man ja mal auf die Seite gucken. Das ist ja KAMENET und die machen auch IPv6 und den ganzen Kram, die sind ganz gut drauf. Machen japanischen U-Bahn-Codes sozusagen. Eine U-Bahn-Code, ein Kampfcode.
Michael! Ja, das war's eigentlich.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also zur Sicherheit.
Ist ein guter Ruf gemacht.
Ist ein guter Vorbild.
Alles nickt.
Alles nickt. Draußen sind sogar schon applaudierende Fans gekommen. Vor den Nachrichten noch kurz. Christian, der will sich nämlich beschweren. Hallo, Christian.
Der Christian will nämlich was? Das hab ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Der will sich nämlich beschweren.
Ich will mich beschweren. Nein, das möchte ich nicht. Aber das wollte ich natürlich auch sagen.
Was jetzt?
Euro Net Homepage angesagt hab. Und zwar funktioniert der Nette Link für Berlin nicht. Computer Chaos Club Berlin. Eigentlich wollte ich sagen nämlich, dass ich bis heute Mittag vorhatte, mir das nämlich auch zu kaufen, zumindest die kleinen Seiten für ein Netzwerk.
Was genau geht da jetzt gerade nicht?
Du hattest gerade keinen Kopfhörer, Angel. Er hat gesagt, ach so, der Link, der nicht geht.
Von WCZC.de.
Ja, von WCZC.de kann ich noch ansagen.
Und zwar unter chaosradio.ccc.de slash berlin. Die hab ich irgendwo gefunden, muss ich mal nachgucken.
Naja, da kann ich so fern was zu sagen, dass unser Webserver im Moment im Umbau befindlich ist. Ich seh gerade jemand fix das gerade. Und in den nächsten Tagen kommt auf jeden Fall ein neuer Webserver dahin. Alles wird besser, alles wird gut. Datenbank-basierter Webserver.
Christian, du hättest dir fast eine Karte gekauft.
Naja, mir geht es darum, dass ich selber auf dem Server im Internet hab. Da steht über mir zu Hause. Ich geh noch zur Schule, mach mein Abitur dieses Jahr. Und ich hatte vor, da in der Schule natürlich an einem Netzwerk ein bisschen mitzuadministrieren. Meine Interessen liegen da auch so mehr unter Linux. Und hatte das natürlich so um unseren Administrator, den AVM-Kraft, das natürlich vorgeschlagen. Das ist ja natürlich alles sehr toll, ist Linux und so. Und hatte sich auch für interessiert. Ist aber nicht so. Und jetzt auch, da wir mehrere Häuser haben, ist eher auf die Idee gekommen, das mit Waveline mitzuverbinden. Das haben wir jetzt auch getan. Ich befinde mich da jetzt nur nicht mehr so mit drin. Ich war noch am Anfang dabei, als ich festgestellt habe, dass alles gar nicht so toll ist dort. Und dachte mir, na gut, wenn er mich, ich glaube im Hip-Hop-Bereich darf man das ditten oder so. Wenn er mich da halt immer so schräg anmacht, dann kann ich mich auch ruhig von außen mal eng klingen. Mal so einen Drucker laufen lassen zum Beispiel.
Fliege ich auch schon gekommen.
Also nichts Böses, nicht wirklich. Na ja, da habe ich mich immer so heute erkundigt. Ich war heute im Geschäft. Wie teuer denn alles sowas ist, aber die haben absolut keine Ahnung davon. Und da dachte ich mir, da kriege ich das heute von euch vielleicht raus. Gerade, wenn man dann nicht so spannend ist.
Wie?
Na, wenn ihr dann mal so schön redet über die Krankenhäuser. Die waren ein bisschen langgezogen, war das davor zum Beispiel.
Wir reden doch danach weiter.
Und dann redet ihr danach weiter. So lange Musik dazwischen.
Was? Wir sollen nicht so lange Musik dazwischen machen?
Ja, ihr redet doch sonst immer so viel.
Na ja, machen wir erstmal eine Musik. Christian, sind da noch mehr Leute? Die Musik hat da gar nicht zugehört. Das Wetter. Nachts kann es vereinzelt regnen. Die Temperaturen sinken auf zwölf bis acht Grad. Morgen wird es wolkenreich. Dabei bilden sich Schauer, örtlich auch Gewitter. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 17 und 21 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gesine.
Mit der Entschiedigung der ehemaligen NS-Zwangsarbeiter kann begonnen werden. Der Bundestag stellte die erforderliche Rechtssicherheit für deutsche Unternehmen fest. Das heißt, den Firmen drohen in den USA keine Klagen von Betroffenen. Für die Entschädigung stehen insgesamt 10 Milliarden Mark zur Verfügung. Die Regierung in Potsdam stellt in diesem Jahr 30 Millionen Mark für das Projekt Tolerantes Brandenburg bereit. Das Geld soll für Jugendarbeit und das Aktionsprogramm gegen Neonazis ausgegeben werden. Außerdem soll es ab dem kommenden Schul-IA verbindliche Lehrpläne zum Thema Rechtsextremismus geben. In Paris ist der frühere französische Außenminister Dumas wegen Bestechlichkeit zu sechs Monaten Haft verurteilt worden. Er musste sich im Zusammenhang mit der Schmiergeld-Affäre um den Ölkonzern 11 Agitänen verantworten. Sachsens Ministerpräsident Biedenkopf muss rund 120.000 Mark an die Landeskasse zurückzahlen. Ihm wurde vorgeworfen, das Landespersonal in seiner Villa sowie den Dienstwahn privat genutzt zu haben. Der Europäische Fußballverband UEFA hat die Stadionsperre gegen Galatasaray Istanbul aufgehoben. Sie war nach den Ausschreitungen der Zuschauer beim Champions-League-Spiel gegen Real Madrid Anfang April verhängt worden.
Bisschen Verkehr, Gesine.
Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100-Lichtenberg Richtung Wilmersdorf. Vollsperrung zwischen Tempelhof und Buschkrug. Erlegen gegen Bauarbeiten von 21 Uhr bis 4 Uhr.
Fritz präsentiert. Das Finks Pop Treffen zu Finks. Das Finks Pop Treffen in Berlin mit Waxengill und Loonique. Samstag, 2. Juni ab 22 Uhr im Bastard im Prater Prenzlauer Berg.
Krügs, könntest du bitte wieder Musik anmachen?
Danke.
Bist du in Vollerrand?
Was? Nee, bin ich eigentlich gar nicht. Also ich finde das ist okay. Ich muss ja auch wach bleiben. Chaosradio 61, Wavelines Security. Ich hörte eben das Wort Anekdote.
Ja, ja, da hat der Holger große Augen, dass wir Anekdotestationen gesagt haben.
Wir unterhalten uns ja hier auch nebenbei.
Genau.
In Unterhaltungssendungen.
Es gab halt noch ein ganz nettes Netz.
Auf der Suche nach Krankenhausnetzen?
Ja, das war sogar in der Nähe von einem.
Genau.
Eigentlich war der Empfang sogar am stärksten, direkt vor dem Haupteingang. Aber das Netz hieß Energy.
Echt?
Und das finde ich auf der anderen Straßenseite dieser Radiosender.
Wie hieß der doch gleich?
Ich komm nicht drauf. Irgendwas mit E.
Und die haben irgendwie lustige Computernamen. So irgendwie Chefcomputer.
Ne, Apple 3-Server.
Genau. Die haben auch die Nachrichten und Verkehr haben sie auch im Rechner.
Was ist 23.42 Uhr? Wir müssen eine Gedenkminute für das Adams einlegen.
Genau. Für die, die es nicht wissen. Douglas Adams ist vor zweieinhalb Wochen gestorben.
An Sport.
An Sport?
Ja, meines Wissens ein Herzinfarkt beim Hometrainer benutzen, nicht? Eine Minute ist zu lang.
Genau. Sonst schalte die Telekom ab. Tut uns leid, Tim.
Habt ihr das nur bei der Station ausprobiert oder habt ihr euch noch ein paar andere rausgesucht?
Nö, wir sind da eigentlich nicht bei Zufall vorbei.
Wir wurden halt mit IP beworfen und fanden das dann ganz klasse.
Also irgendwann war es dann schon so ein bisschen anstrengend, so irgendwie morgens um halb sechs in der Woche doch endlich mal nach Hause.
Einfach nach Hause und dann, nein, alle heuten, sofort. Nee, ist das schon anstrengend, man hat es nicht leicht.
Nee, also vor allen Dingen dann so nach vier ist die Quote pro Kilometer von letzten Nacht eingestiegen.
Nach vier Uhr morgens.
Man ist schon absichtlich irgendwelche Strecken gefahren, die...
Woher dachten vielleicht ist der wesentliche Kuba schneller als das Bett?
Was? Also noch eine Anekdote. Dann machen wir mal die kleine Anekdotenliste auf jetzt bitte.
Ach Gott, das ist jetzt aber die letzte.
Dann müssen wir doch nicht immer alles aus dem Nase ziehen.
Wenn die Zuhörer irgendwie vorhaben, so in größere Hotels zu gehen, dann haben sie einfach mal das Feature, dass denen da auch eine Base Station hingestellt wird, dass man auf dem Zimmer einfach mal Internet hat. Das ist cool.
Ja, das finden die ganzen Politiker und die Lobby bestimmt auch ganz cool, wenn sie ins, wie heißt das?
Adlon?
Nein, so ein anderes großes Ding.
Ah, dieses Ding, was da am Landwehrkanal...
So schräg ging, oder vom Bundesverband?
Genau, und die machen halt auch Internet nach draußen einmal viel und machen halt irgendwie auch das interne Netz nach draußen. Genau, und wir zählen jetzt nicht, was wir da mitgelesen haben.
Wissen die, dass sie das machen oder erfahren sie es möglicherweise jetzt gerade im Radio?
Wenn sie die Sendung hören.
Man kann sich ja nicht aus dem Motorboot mieten und einfach vor diesem Hotel festmachen.
Naja, das Problem ist, dass man bei so einem Hotel hat, man ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Also ein Hotel hat da, wenn die das Netz für Gäste anbieten, dann lohnt es sich eigentlich nicht den Gästen noch einen Key zu geben, weil dann hat jeder einen Key, das wäre totaler Unsinn. Also was die tun sollten, wir dann einfach mal ihr internes Netz von diesen Gästen intern als abklemmen, damit sie da kein Problem bekommen und vor allen Dingen ihre Gäste mal deutlich darauf hinweisen, dass jeder in diesem Netz ihre E-Mails mitlesen kann.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich? Ich meine, die Polizei, die kriegen doch jetzt auch irgendwie alle ganz tolle neue Computer.
Die Polizei? Also die kriegen nicht mal Computer, also...
Was war das denn? Das sieht aus wie dein Akku irgendwie. Klasse.
Ich glaube, da hinten ist noch dieser Orgel.
Sehr gut dann.
Unglaublich. Ich habe da auch mal mit...
Die Polizei ist arm und hat das nicht, oder was? Das wäre auch nochmal interessant.
Wenn sie einen Computer haben pro Dienststelle, meistens müssen sie sich irgendwie so die Schreibmaschine teilen und irgendwie einer hat dann einen Computer, die wäre noch demnächst in absehbarer Zeit.
Brauchst du ja bloß den Datenschutz angucken. Ich meine, das ist Datenschutz.
Genau. Also die haben eigentlich kein Geld für Welflernkarten, deswegen wird die Polizei irgendwie... Wie will man das rechtfertigen? Dass die Polizisten mit Laptops durch die Gegend rennen dürfen innerhalb ihrer Dienststelle und wenn sonst kein Geld für gar nichts da ist bei der Polizei. Ich glaube, da müssen sie sich einfach mal...
Hast du die Staatsanwaltschaft schon mal ausprobiert?
Also in den Behördengebieten haben wir nichts gesehen. Das war irgendwie relativ eindeutig, dass die Technologie da noch nicht angekommen ist.
Ja, wir haben da irgendwie auch Regierung irgendwie alles mal abgefahren, weil man könnte denken, das ist vielleicht ein auswärtiges Amt oder so. Die sind irgendwie groß unterwegs.
Ach, ihr wart das mit diesem Telegramm aus...
Okay, wir müssen jetzt leider erschießen.
Genau, ich kann es dir erzählen, aber dann muss ich dich hinterher erschießen. Du meinst von der Regierung?
Alle beide?
Chaosradio 61 auf Fritz, 10 Minuten vor 12 haben wir's und wir reden über Waveline Security. Nee, eigentlich reden wir gar nicht über Waveline Security, sondern wir lassen uns die ganze Zeit, also ich, ich lass mir und euch liebe Hörfunkfreunde Anekdoten erzählen über nicht sichere Wavelines. Wie mach ich es denn sicher? Also jetzt kauf ich mir so eine Base Station und so eine Karte, bin mit 1000 Mark ungefähr dabei und hab dann einen unsicheren Krempel oder wie?
Na eigentlich nicht, eigentlich ist es ganz einfach.
Einfach mal die Bedienungsanleitung durchlesen.
Genau.
Ja, aber da hört es ja schon auf, die Dinger sollen gefälligst intuitiv gehen.
Geht auch. Also, du kannst irgendwie für die Base Station einmal Software, ganz einfach, kannst du klicken.
Kann man bloß Sicherheit anklicken.
Ach echt, ganz groß. Sicherheit an, kann man sagen, verstecke mal mein Netzwerk vor den Leuten, die vorbeilaufen. Gibt sowieso einen großen, irgendwie ganzen Bildschirm. Klick da drauf und mach das. Scheint überlesen zu werden, irgendwie in den meisten Firmen.
Vielleicht erklärst du nochmal kurz diese Sache mit dem Versteckt und mit dem Verschließt.
Genau, mit dem Versteckt oder Verschlüsselt. Generell haben so Netzwerke einfach mal einen Namen, diese auch immer fleißig nach draußen brüllen und sagen hier, ich bin so ein Wafler-Netzwerk und ich möchte, dass ihr euch irgendwie bei mir anschließt. Das können wir auch sein lassen. Also man kann dem der Base Station sagen, dass sie das nicht tun soll. Und dann muss man schon als Client, also als jemand, der dieses Netzwerk benutzen möchte, muss man dem Netzwerk seinen Namen erzählen. Also man muss das Netzwerk wissen. Und erst dann kommt man rein. Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Man gibt den Netzwerknamen ein und klickt diesen Button, mache mal verstecktes Netzwerk. Dann klickt man an und dann ist es eigentlich gut. Dann muss jeder, der draußen an diesem Netzwerk teilhaben möchte, diesen Netzwerknamen auch eingeben bei sich. Ansonsten sieht er das Netzwerk erst gar nicht.
Wer ließ es sich aber herausfinden? Relativ simpel. Also zumindest bei IBM.
Ja, aber das ist schon mal das erste, wenn du mal so vor dem Haus stehst von irgendeiner Firma, dann kannst du den Netzwerknamen immer noch raten, wie vielleicht die Firma heißt, aber...
Kurze Verwirrung.
Aber das sollte schon mal reichen, für die Leute, die irgendwie vorbeigehen und keinen Plan haben, was das für ein Netzwerk sein könnte. Und müsste man erstmal auch wissen, dass da ein Netzwerk ist. Also das sieht man ja dann nicht. Dann blinkt das auch nicht so hübsch auf der Karte.
Was man dazu aber noch erwähnen soll, ist, dass dieses Verfahren ist halt client-based. Das heißt also, die Sicherheit findet tatsächlich nicht in der Base-Station statt, sondern die Base-Station übermittelt nur ein Fleck an die Netzwerkkarte, wo drin steht, pass auf, wenn du dieses Netz siehst, dann verschweige das mal, als du den neuesten richtigen Netzwerknamen bei dir eingegeben. Das heißt also, wenn tatsächlich jemand es mal schafft, eine andere Firmware, also eine andere Low-Level-Software für diese Waveline-Karten zu schreiben, dann ist es überhaupt kein Problem, auch Netze zu finden, die nur hinten sind, also nur versteckt sind.
Was wäre denn die Alternative zum Verstecken?
Naja, die Alternative zum Verstecken?
Ist halt WEP zusätzlich.
Zusätzlich zu dem Ganzen kann man halt auch noch WEP einsetzen. Das ist halt mit in diesem IEEE 802.11 Standard festgelegt.
Der Standard für Waveline.
Genau. Das ist quasi eine 40-Bit-Verschlüsselung. Dazu hat man so einen Key. Und damit wird dieser gesamte Trafik einfach verschleiert, der über die Luft geht. Das ist allerdings auch kein richtiger Schutz, kein guter Schutz. Das nennt sich WEP, Wired Equivalent Privacy. Also bietet im Endeffekt die Sicherheit, die man hat, als wenn man sich in einem verkabelten Netzwerk befindet. Das ist halt eigentlich nur eine Verschleierung. Aber das ist auch den meisten nicht klar. Die lesen halt verschlüsselt. Ach, jetzt bin ich ja sicher. Aber es ist halt so, ja, diese Firmware, wenn die irgendwann mal von irgendwelchen Leuten neu erfunden wird, sozusagen, dass man die auf diese Firmware, also dass man die Firmware damit austauschen kann, dann hat man Zugriff auf die untersten Layer, diesen Linklayer, und kann dann da schon eine Menge mitmachen. Also man weiß halt, man sieht halt die Netznamen. Man hat auch die Möglichkeit, diese Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen einfach auszuhebeln. Dieser ganze Schutzmechanismus wäre dann einfach mal weg.
Das Problem, das ist dann Ende der Fahnenstange, was Sicherheit angeht?
Nein, nein, nein. Gibt es da was wirklich sicheres? Man kann ja auch noch so, was vorhin schon angesprochen wurde, mit diesem IPSEC, PGPnet oder wie auch immer es hieß, so IPSEC einzusetzen, darauf kommen wir aber auch nachher noch. Weil das bietet dann einfach erstmal so richtig Sicherheit. Selbst wenn irgendwie dieser WEP-Schutz dort ausgeheuelt wird.
Ich verstehe. Das ist hier der Blue Moon auf Fritz. Das ist die Sendung, bei der man anrufen kann. Wenn man insbesondere über Waveline, deren Sicherheit und deren Unsicherheit reden will, das hier ist die Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Und Steffen hat angerufen.
Hallo. Hi, Steffen. Tag.
Ich lese hier nur Für Großes Klinikum. Das macht mich neugierig.
Das sollte heißen, ich will Für Großes Klinikum in die Bresche springen.
Ach so.
Das ist zum Beispiel das Klinikum Steglitz, wo ich weiß, also wo ich aus sehr gesicherter Quelle weiß, dass da ein Wavelan existiert und das eine Wavelan bindet einen Rechner in einer Außenstelle an, was über Richtfunk irgendwie angebunden ist. Also da gibt es nicht wirklich was. Auf der Intensivstation gibt es überhaupt kein Wavelan. Die Ärzte dürfen da gar nicht mit Laptops rumrennen und ja.
Es hängt halt wirklich tatsächlich immer von den Leuten vor Ort ab und wie sicherheitsbewusst die sind. Also oft genug ist es ja so, dass der Datenschutzbeauftragte zum Beispiel halt nur irgendein Arzt ist, der nebenbei dazu verurteilt ist, den Datenschutzbeauftragten zu meme und oft genug die EDV auch einigermaßen überfordert ist. Aber es ist schön zu hören, dass es nicht überall so ist.
Nee, also da hat sich jemand wirklich Gedanken drüber gemacht und der Plan wurde schon mal verworfen, dass man einen Wavelan einführt aus Sicherheitsgründen. Na gut, der erste Grund war Kosten, aber gut, das ist halt öffentlicher Dienst.
Die Fragen stellen sich jetzt, wie kommen wir an die Daten, die Patientendaten vom Klinikum Steglitz ran?
Wie sicher ist denn dein Netzwerk? Was hast du denn genau gemacht? Hast du da WEP angeschaltet und das Netzwerk versteckt oder noch mehr?
Dieses eine Funkladen, was ich da sagte.
Ja genau, dieses fernangebundene Funkladen.
Ja, entzieht sich meine Kenntnis. Ich bin nicht Administrator da. Ich hab's bloß aus ziemlich sicherer Quelle da aus dem Rechenzentrum.
Das Schöne bei diesen Funkladen ist ja, dass die wirklich sehr gewündelt sind. Also ich meine, bei Richtfunkladen, dass die wirklich nur einen kleinen Kegel aufmachen, dass man diese Netze auch schwer findet. Das ist das eine. Aber wenn dieses Netzwerk wirklich nur mit WEP und dem hidden Network verschlüsselt oder versteckt ist, dann bietet das einfach mal keine Sicherheit.
Ja gut, das Netz geht von Dach zu Dach. Da hat sich die Verkabelung nicht gelohnt. Und das sieht schon komisch aus, wenn man da mit dem Wagen dazwischen fährt und eine Antenne hochfährt.
Man kann es vielleicht hinter die Antenne stellen. Das ist ja an der Antenne nicht zu Ende. Wenn man hinter der Antenne diese Linie mal verlängert, dann kann man da vielleicht noch ein Dach finden, wo man dann auch noch das Signal kriegt. Also ganz sicher ist das irgendwie alles nie nicht.
Wie weit geht denn so die normale Richtfunkstrecke? Geht das dann so einen Kilometer weit? Oder kann man das noch ein bisschen einstellen? Oder wie jetzt wirklich die Empfangs- oder Sendeleistung ist von so einer Stelle?
Das hängt ja irgendwie von der Antenne auch ab. Also was für eine Antenne, du hast wie viel Dezibel. Und ja, je nachdem, ob das da irgendwie ruckelt oder sonst was ist.
Und vom Wetter natürlich auch.
Ob eine Taube dazwischen sitzt oder... Nee, aber diese Außenstelle ist auch nicht so angebunden, dass sie an Patientendaten rankommt. Also das kann ich aussagen. Die haben eine Internetleitung da, Punkt. Und dann kommt man halt nicht an die Patientendaten ran. Außer man kriegt jetzt den Weg übers Internet hin.
Na gut, das war meistens die Firebosch-Mittel der Funkhalter. Können wir uns ja mal angucken.
Alles klar.
Ja, Fragen zu Wavelan und Wavelan Sicherheit beantworten wir natürlich auch hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz unter dieser Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam, 7097110.
Und jetzt wollen wir noch ein bisschen Chill-Out-Musik hören. Das Chaosradio 61 in Gnumunow-Fritz. Es ist eine Minute nach Mitternacht. Wir reden über Waveline Security und Waveline. Also sagen wir mal Waveline im Allgemeinen und deren Sicherheit. Im Besonderen, wenn ihr drüber reden wollt mit uns oder Fragen zu diesem Thema habt oder auch Anekdoten erzählen wollt, wo ihr denn offene Netze gefunden habt. Vielleicht wollt ihr das ja der Öffentlichkeit mitteilen, damit sich demnächst viele Menschen vor dem Haus einfinden. Ruft uns an.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110. Ich bin ein Wobben.
Guten Morgen Jendrik. Ja genau.
Überraschend.
Nee, an Zeichwald der Expo. Expo 2000, sehr originell. Das war eigentlich versteckt. Und da konnte man so ziemlich überall ran, also nach außen hin, was gut abgestimmt, über Proxy-Server und Firewalls, also zum Internet hin. Aber intern war da gar nichts. Da konnte man sich alles angucken, Überwachungskameras etc.
Und was heißt, wenn es versteckt war, wie hast du es gefunden?
Ich habe einfach Expo 2000 eingegeben.
Hast du da IP-basierte Überwachungskameras gesehen?
Nein, man hat halt wie bei einer Webcam nur die einzelnen Ruckelwälder gesehen, aber man konnte sich halt so ein paar Sachen angucken.
Das ist ja cool.
Man konnte auch vorne die Eingangstür öffnen, also ein Krimskram drüber und Strom ausschalten. Nicht schlecht.
Hast du das denn wenigstens auch gemacht?
Nein, haben wir uns nicht getraut. Also ich dachte nur zwei Freunde. Wir haben uns das nicht getraut, weil wir dachten, naja, dann passiert vielleicht noch irgendein Scheiß und die fangen an, uns hier anzupeilen.
Würde das gehen, Jungs?
Na ja, etwas schwieriger.
Also Wafeland hat irgendwie einen nicht geringen Frequenzhub?
Also Wafeland wird auf ein paar Fahnen übertragen, was Spat-Spektrum heißt. Das heißt also, dass ein relativ breites Frequenzband benutzt wird, um die einzelnen Bits tatsächlich darüber zu verteilen. Das heißt also, ein Bit, was gesendet wird, wird nicht auf derselben Frequenz gesendet, wie das nächste Bit, was danach gesendet wird usw. Und das heißt also, dass der Pegelhub auf der Frequenz ist relativ gering. Und zudem sendet Wafeland halt bei 2, 4 Gigahertz. Und das ist irgendwie, naja, so vom Peilen her schon ein bisschen nervig, weil es halt überall reflektiert wird und stark abgeschümmt wird und so. Also es ist halt nicht besonders gut zu peilen, die Frequenz. Und also gerade in bebaute Gegenden. Insofern muss man sich da eigentlich eher Gedanken machen, dass einen Wachmänner irgendwie mit geschultem Auge sehen, wie man auf der Bank ist mit seinem Laptop, aber nicht so, dass man da wirklich hafmäßig angepeilt wird.
Naja, ich kenne das nur vom CB-Pfunk und da kann man sich auf 10 Meter genauer etwas anpeilen. Und da waren wir uns nicht so sicher auf jeden Fall. Wir haben uns die ganzen Bewachungskameras und so ein bisschen angeguckt.
Nicht schlecht.
Wobei das mit den Türen hätte ich wirklich großartig gefunden, dann hätte ich dir echt noch einen Orden verliehen.
Nee, das haben wir uns ja nicht getraut. Das war uns zu gefährlich. Aber das Ganze kann man auch bei der deutschen Bahngut machen. Da kann man, aber wenn man gut ist und sich einfach nur in das Netzwerk, gibt es jetzt im IT diese Netzwerke und Internetverbindungen, dass man da drüber auf die Server von der Bahn, von den Weichenstellungen zugreifen kann.
Das glaube ich nicht. Also ehrlich gesagt...
Ich habe das jetzt nur als Gerücht gehört.
Nee, das hätte ich für Unsinn. Also ich weiß ein bisschen was darüber, wie die Bahn ihr Netzwerk da aufbaut. Und es gibt da keine direkten IP-Verbindungen zwischen irgendwas, was Betriebstechnik ist und dem externen Netz. Also da haben sie sich schon ein bisschen Mühe gegeben.
Das habe ich bis jetzt nur gerüchteweise gehört. Also ich weiß nicht, wie lange es noch ging, aber das war ziemlich am Anfang und das heißt...
Naja, auf der Expo hat ja irgendwie auch ein Mitglied des CCC vor einem Jahr auch mal ein paar herumfahrende Roboter entdeckt, die auch alle über Welflern vernetzt waren. Und da war irgendwie auf jedem dieser einzelnen Roboter irgendwie so ein kleines Linux drauf, irgendwie kein Passwort, weil die sich nicht gedacht haben, dass da irgendwer mit Welflern ein Verräter vorbeikommt. Und der hat sich da einfach hingesetzt, hat dann die Roboter dann einfach mal da, ja, angepingt, Tellnet drauf gemacht, hat dann ein Menü gekriegt und konnte dann die Roboter durch die Gegend fahren lassen oder ausschalten, oder so wurde.
Meinst du, diese kleinen Fußballspielenden Hunde, die es da gab, oder?
Nee, das war ja der RoboCup von den Unis.
Genau, das hat mich einer von meiner Schule gemacht, Jan Lukas hieß der, und der hat die mit einem Funksnetzwerk ein Störsignal hingeschickt, die sind immer gegen die Wand gelaufen. Aber das fing mir etwas auf, mit dem Laptop daneben zu stehen.
Jendrik, ich gehe davon aus, dass du dich bis an ein Lebensende darüber agern wirst, dass du die Nummer auf der Expo nicht bis zum Ende gehört hast.
Naja, es war morgen einfach zu gefährlich in dem Augenblick.
Gucken wir mal, wo ist denn die nächste Expo eigentlich? Ich weiß nicht, jemand. Jendrik, danke für deinen Anruf. Oh, hier blinkt es noch. Noch ein Anruf? Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja, hier ist Michael. Mit so anderem Thema, nicht direkt Waveline, sondern Bluetooth, soll ja demnächst der Riesenhype werden.
Wie sieht es da mit Sicherheit aus?
Alle gucken einander an.
Na ja, Bluetooth ist ja auf andere Anwendungsbereiche primär ausgerichtet als Waveline. Das hat ja eine wesentlich kürzere Reichweite.
Aber die große Variante kann da auch 100 Meter.
Die Problematik ist halt, dass der Datendurchsatz wesentlich geringer ist als bei Waveline.
Ja gut, aber wenn das in deinem PC hängt, dann ist es aber auch gefährlich.
Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass man da tatsächlich noch eine Menge Schabernack drüber treiben kann. Bisher ist es so, dass ich noch nicht glaube, dass sich Bluetooth so schnell durchsetzen wird, wie die Leute immer glauben. Weil momentan ist noch niemand wirklich tatsächlich mit Karten auf dem Markt, die man real kaufen kann, also außer developer Kids. Und insofern wird sich ein bisschen hinziehen, wogegen Wave dann halt eine Technologie ist, die jetzt tatsächlich gerade schon in großem Maße eingesetzt wird. Bei Bluetooth ist es so, dass es auch ein paar Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gibt, weil wir sich natürlich auch ein bisschen Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, wie man es verhindern kann. Aber soweit ich gesehen habe, wurden auch schon die ersten Papiere publiziert, wie man diese Verschlüsselung bei Bluetooth angreifen kann. Also ja, ich meine, es wird halt alles immer schlimmer.
Ja und halt dann, wenn es dann wirklich Massenmarkt wird, dann ist es halt auch gefährlicher. Wie die Industrie halt sagt, für jedermann, für Funktastaturen und alles, dann wird es halt sehr gefährlich, wenn das jeder benutzt.
Dann muss man schauen, wie man das Rauschen dann auch irgendwie unterdrückt, weil wenn wirklich es jeder benutzt, dann hat man da auch...
Was war denn das jetzt für ein Beepen? Ach so, bei dir? Ne, alles klar.
Wir kriegen uns einen Herzschrückmacher hier.
Umso billiger die ganzen Teile werden, umso größer werden die...
Verbreitet.
Eigentlich wäre ich größer. Die verbrennen sich dann überall. Ja, das mit diesen Funktastaturen und so. Da gab es ja auch schon eine Meldung, dass da irgendein Unternehmen rausgefunden hat, dass irgendeine Bankgesellschaft so piep.
Ja gut, ich muss Schluss machen.
Alles klar, Michael.
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Also die Sache mit den Funktastaturen ist tatsächlich auch eine interessante Anmerkung. Also da hat man von der Weide schon mal drüber nachgedacht, müssen wir echt mal ausprobieren. Die CT tatsächlich schneller, hat es auch publiziert. Es ist so, dass es Tastaturen und Mäuse gibt, die über Funk an den Rechner angeboten werden. Warum man kein lästiges Kabel dazwischen, wenn man auf der Couch liegt, um die Filme umzuschalten. Die gehen halt auch über Funk und sind genau gar nicht verschlüsselt. Da ist es tatsächlich so, dass man nur einen Empfänger gleicher Bauart braucht und dann tatsächlich die Mausbewegungen und die Tastaturanschläge direkt nachvollziehen kann auf dem eigenen Rechner. Wenn man einfach so einen Empfänger ransteckt und den Kanal findet, auf dem der andere ist. Der Effekt ist dann tatsächlich, dass man alles sieht, was derjenige mit der Funktastatur tippt. Also Passwörter, Tannennummern fürs Banking und so weiter. Die Reichweite ist nicht besonders hoch, aber man kann mit einer kleinen Interne da auch ein bisschen was tun. Also da kann man sich auch eine Menge Spaß mit haben.
Spaß mit Funknetzen, unser Thema im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Und ihr könnt mitreden, wenn ihr wollt, unter dieser Nummer hier.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Chaosradio 61 ist das, was ihr hier gerade hört, auf Fritz. Wir reden über Wave-Lan, also über Funknetze quasi und deren Sicherheit, deren Anekdoten, wenn ihr welche habt, Funknetze, also zum Beispiel, hey Mensch, geht doch mal dahin, da gibt's kostenloses Internet und zwar im Grünen. Dann ruft man hier an und sagt uns das, wenn ihr Erfahrungen habt, wenn ihr Ängste habt oder Fragen zu Wave-Lan, ruft im Chaosradio an, das ist die Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ja, hallo hier ist Birger. Ja, ich ruf euch aus Dortmund an irgendwie und ich verfolge, dass ihr ganz interessiert. Irgendwie auch habe ich auch mal ein paar Kritikpunkte zu dem Ganzen, was ihr da so von euch gebt. Ich habe den Eindruck, euch geht es irgendwie nur bedingt um wirkliche Sicherheit, weil ich, wenn ich höre, dass ihr quasi, ja, quasi irgendwelche fremden Netze irgendwie anzapft und so, dann, was den Leuten auch noch sagt, ja, da ist ein Problem vielleicht. Letztendlich habe ich den Eindruck, euch geht es eigentlich quasi mehr darum, einen eigenen Sport hier zu vermitteln, weil ihr hier sagt, wir zeigen euch doch mal, wie wir euch hacken können. Den Eindruck, den kriege ich hier alles an mit.
Naja, ich meine, das Problem ist halt einfach, dass da draußen jede Menge offene Wärftennetze sind. Einige davon sind wirklich kritisch. Und insofern irgendwie, was denkst du, was irgendwie besser ist, dass es offen bleibt und niemand davon weiß? Oder dass es irgendwie Leute vielleicht mal losgehen und irgendwie ihrerseits in ihrer Umgebung mal gucken, was für Netze sind, und dann die Leute darauf hinweisen, dass es dann ein Problem gibt?
Ich sehe das aber als ein zweisteiliges Schmerz. Ich darf mal gleich erzählen, ich hab jetzt irgendwie in der FH, irgendwie, wo ich bin noch am Studieren, in Informatikbereich, irgendwie, da haben wir das Problem, dass über Ostern einer unserer zentralen Rechner gehackt wurde, irgendwie, und als Konsequenz der Administrator dann losgegangen ist und das Ding, das System dermassen dicht gemacht hat, dass ich als Nutzer meines Unix-Accounts quasi nichts mehr machen kann mit dem Rechner. Sowas gibt es nämlich auch, dass die Kehrseite von Sicherheit so hoch ist, dass ich das System nicht mehr richtig...
Naja, Sicherheit ist immer eine Abwägung. Wenn dein Administrator ein Idiot ist, kann ich auch nichts dafür. Also, ich meine, es ist tatsächlich so, wofür brauchst du einen Rechner bei solchen Massen-Account-Rechnern wie Unis? Es ist immer schwer, die richtige Balance zu finden zwischen dem, was der User darf und dem, was der User nicht darf. Und gerade Unis sind halt irgendwie doch ziemlich restriktiv konfigurierte Orte, weil die Leute natürlich auch keine Lust haben, die da die Administration machen, dauernd allen Problemen hinterher zu rennen. Aber naja, Herrgott, also meine Philosophie dabei ist halt einfach lieber, ein Fehler wird tatsächlich gefunden. Und bevor da irgendwas Böses mit angestellt wird und den Leuten mitgeteilt, sodass sie was dagegen tun können, bleibt es verschwiegen. Und da passiert dann halt irgendwelcher Mist mit von Leuten, die nicht auf die Idee kommen, Bescheid zu sagen, sondern da halt kriminelle Energie verfolgen.
Ja, es ist denn das, was ihr jetzt beschrieben habt, ich denke jetzt gerade an den vorletzten Hörer, den ihr da hattet, der meintet, das ist doch jetzt cool gewesen, auf der Expo da irgendwas zu machen oder so. Ja, ist das nicht doch letztendlich auch eine Art Sport, ihr da auch auf dem Feld?
Ich meine, das muss ja auch Spaß machen, oder? Du denkst doch nicht, dass ihr nach Feierabend mit Technik 4000 von Mark irgendwie durch die Gegend fahren wollt, und es irgendwie der Bürger sind umtreibt. Sondern es muss natürlich auch ein bisschen Spaß machen, solche Sachen. Das ist einfach so. Und wenn man irgendwie den Spaß mit dem Tatsächlich Nützlichen verbinden kann, dann ist das schon umso besser.
Tschau. Stichwort Sport. Ich mein, das ist doch eigentlich, also wenn ich jetzt mal so ein Handheld, also so ein I-Pack, irgendwann dann mal für 250 Mark kriege, das wird ja früher oder später denke ich auch mal der Fall sein, dass ich ein brauchbares Gerät für den Preis habe, und diese Karten auch nur noch in Huni kosten, dann gehe ich mal unter 500 Mark durch die Gegend und klingel nicht mehr an fremden Türen, renne dann weg, sondern gucke mir fremde Netze an oder?
Das ist irgendwie in Amerika gar nicht gäbe. Also da gibt es irgendwie einige Eltern von irgendwelchen Kindern, die bisher irgendwie nur wirklich bleich in ihrem Zimmer gesessen haben und irgendwie sich nicht an... die wollen irgendwie plötzlich das Auto von Papa haben oder setzen sich mal in die öffentlichen Personennahverkehrsmittel und fahren durch die Gegend und suchen auch wirklich Netze, so setzen sich in die Tieffarage, hat irgendwie so in Amerika so einen Namen, heißt War Driving. Und das gibt es also, Waveline Netze gibt es halt in Amerika irgendwie schon länger als hier in Deutschland.
Also es war da länger billiger als hier.
Wäre es sich lohnen, die Dinger zu importieren?
Also Elektronik importieren, das in den USA lohnt sich tatsächlich überhaupt nicht.
Ich denke, es ist billiger.
Es war da billiger.
Achso, es war.
Damals sind ja auch Gefallen dann. Bloß, dass es da in einigen Regionen dann massiv Netz gab, also dass es...
Also bis zu Silicon Valley zum Beispiel ist halt irgendwie, wenn man den Berichten von da drüben trauen darf, die Netzdichte noch deutlich höher als hier so in Berlin. Naja, also das sagt natürlich auch ein bisschen was aus über die Netzdurchdrehung allgemein in der Gesellschaft. Da ist es wohl tatsächlich so, dass es irgendwie so ein gewissen Volkssport geworden ist.
Da freue ich mich doch dann drauf mal.
Wenn sie gerade Strom hatten, dann hatten sie auch Netz.
Ja, auch der CCC muss von irgendwas leben und darum machen wir jetzt Werbung, ja? Also von irgendwas muss der CCC leben, also machen wir jetzt Werbung.
Hier, schauen sie sich diesen ungenutzten Gewerbepark an.
Also ohne meine Bank hätte ich das nie hinbekommen.
Herrlich, diese Verkehrsberuhigung. So unnütz, alles dank meiner Bank.
Meine Bank, das ist die mit den Lederkochern.
Millionenkredite, diskret und ohne Bonitätsprüfung. Bankhaus Landowski in Zehlendorf. Zehlendorf, Zehlendorf, wir haben von all dem nichts gewusst.
Chaosradio 61, Waveline Security ist eigentlich das, worüber wir reden, aber wir mussten eben ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Ich sollte die Geschichte dazu erzählen. Wir haben das dann mal produziert irgendwie vor Wochen und Monaten, als es so rauskam, dass Landowski da bei der Bank Gesellschaft Berlin missgebaut hat und haben das ein paar mal gespielt, einfach um Landowski abzuwatschen damit. Daraufhin haben sich mehrere Leute selbst ans Kreuz genagelt. Die haben nämlich tatsächlich hier angerufen und gefragt, ob sie die Adresse von dieser Bank haben dürften.
Und sie ihre Rufnummer zurückgelassen haben.
Ja, die Adresse dieser Bank ist CDU-Fraktion, Berlin Abgeordnetenhaus. Haben wir eigentlich noch Themen?
Klar.
Ja, ich dachte, man könnte vielleicht auch mal über die ganzen Schutzmechanismen sprechen.
Ja, nachdem du hier einen reingekriegt hast.
Ja, er hält unter einem Berg. Er will irgendwie mehr auf eine Netze. Ist doch viel spaßiger.
Ja, das ist allerdings richtig.
Ja, also WEP, das hatte ich ja vorhin schon mal gesagt. Wired Equivalent Privacy bietet eine Verschleierung des gesamten Trafficsteller übermittelt wird. Was es einem Menschen, der da vor der Tür steht, einfach erstmal schwer macht, da rein zu kommen. Also es bietet halt nicht wirklich Schutz. Also jemand, der zum Beispiel, also ich sag einfach mal Betriebsspionage. Da sind wahrscheinlich Leute hinterher, da an interne Daten ranzukommen. Die opfern auch ein bisschen Zeit. Wenn es also irgendwie gelingen würde, da zum Beispiel diese Firma zu modifizieren, dann könnte man ganz einfach diesen ganzen, dieses ganze Zeug, was da irgendwie verschlüsselt über den Link geht, könnte man einfach mal aufzeichnen. Das wird halt so verschlüsselt, dass das ein Stream-Cypher das Problem ist. Bei diesem ganzen Teil, der ist 24 Bit lang, wird sich oft genug wiederholen.
Das heißt, wenn es gelingt, die Firmware umzuschreiben, was heißt, wenn es gelingt?
Umzuschreiben, einfach Reverse Engineering. Wenn man da irgendwie auf die Karte eine eigene Firmware laden kann, dann kann man da halt direkt auf den Link-Layer zugreifen.
Dass es an den Staaten schon länger billiger gibt, müsste es doch eigentlich auch schon jemanden geben, der das geschafft hat.
Naja, das ist schwer angehalten. Also die Daten über diesen Chip, der da drauf sitzt, die werden halt nicht freigegeben, von Loosen beispielsweise.
Für viel Geld nur. Also normalerweise nur ernstzunehmend. Der Developer kommt da irgendwie daran, sonst ist der Source Code geheim und man weiß auch nicht genau, was für ein Stein da drauf ist, dass man so wie auch nicht so leicht Reverse Engineering kann. Aber es gibt halt jetzt so Projekte, die es auch durchaus geschafft haben, sich den anzugucken mit viel Mühe vor der Kleinarbeit und zu schauen, was die Karte wann macht. Und die haben jetzt auch die Möglichkeit, schon ihre eigene Firmware draufzuspielen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich in absehbarer Zeit auch irgendwie mal der gesamte Verkehr mitgeschnitten werden kann.
Was nennst du absehbare Zeit?
Na ja, sobald die Leute das mal geschafft haben, irgendwie da eine Firmware draufzuspielen, die...
Die Frage sein doch, wie lange warte ich, bis ich mir was kaufe, womit ich wirklich Spaß haben kann?
Noch dieses Jahr, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das Leben ist manchmal einfach hart und Musik kommt nicht da raus, wo man sie raus haben will. Ich, für mein Teil, benutze ja immer CD's. Was benutzt du? Du kannst nicht sprechen? Ach Gott, ja, nee, dann machen wir mal Nachrichten. Eine vor halb eins.
Fritz Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter nachts kann es vereinzelt regnen, die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 8 Grad. Am heutigen Tag wird's wolkenreich. Dabei bilden sich Schauer örtlich auf Gewitter. Die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 17 und 21 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gesine Kühne.
Mit der Entschädigung der ehemaligen NS-Zwangsarbeiter kann begonnen werden. Der Bundestag stellte die erforderliche Rechtssicherheit für deutsche Unternehmen fest. Das heißt, den Firmen drohen in den USA keine Klagen von Betroffenen. Für die Entschädigung stehen insgesamt 10 Milliarden Mark zur Verfügung. Die Regierung in Potsdam stellt in diesem Jahr 30 Millionen Mark für das Projekt Tolerantes Brandenburg bereit. Das Geld soll für Jugendarbeit und das Aktionsprogramm gegen Neonazis ausgegeben werden. Außerdem soll es ab dem kommenden Schuljahr verbindliche Lehrpläne zum Thema Rechtsextremismus geben. Die mazedonische Regierung hat der albanische Minderheit erstmals mehr Rechte in Aussicht gestellt. So werde erwogen, albanisch als zweite Amtssprache einzuführen und die Albaner als eigenes Staatsvolk anzuerkennen. In Paris ist der frühere französische Außenminister Dümmer wegen Bestechlichkeit zu sechs Monaten Haft verurteilt worden. Er musste sich im Zusammenhang mit der Schmiergelder-Affäre um den Ölkonzern 11 AG10 verantworten. Sachsens Ministerpräsident Bienkopf muss rund 120.000 Mark an die Landeskasse zurückzahlen. Ihm wurde vorgeworfen, das Landespersonal in seiner Villa sowie den Dienstwagen privat genutzt zu haben.
Vielen Dank, Gesine.
Zwei Mannschaften im Kampf um die Krone der Basketball Bundesliga. Wer zuerst drei Spiele gewonnen hat, ist Deutscher Meister. Und das erste Spiel steigt am Samstag um 14.45 Uhr. Alba gegen Bonn. Der Klassiker. Samstag, 14.45 Uhr, Max Schmelinghalle. Es bleibt dabei. Alba wird Meister.
Hier ist Chaosradio 61, Wavelan und Wavelan-Sicherheit ist es, worüber wir hier sprechen auf Fritz. Und gibt es eigentlich noch Anekdoten? Also am schlimmsten fand ich die Anekdoten so, wo überall unsichere offene Wavelan-Netze sind, wo man nur mit dem Auto hin muss, um spielen zu können.
Das war echt hart, ne? Also das hat uns da echt den Arsch abgefroren. Also bei Daimler hatten wir dann irgendwie das Problem, dass wir haben dann irgendwann ein Wohnmobil genommen, weil es irgendwie ein bisschen bequemer war, es war einfach so saukalt.
Ey, Moment mal, ihr habt euch ein Wohnmobil genietet, um Daimler auf den Sack zu gehen?
Wir hatten halt noch Rätsel der Familie.
Aber verrat euch die besten Tricks jetzt.
Die sollen ja selber mal losgehen.
Nach Wohnwagen Ausschau halt, nein, unsere Opfer. Nein, unsere Klienten.
Darum, wenn man dir piept, hast du...
Na ja, es ist irgendwie, die mehr Netze wir verraten, desto mehr Spaßnetze verlieren, weil einige sind nicht bedenklich. Also überhaupt nicht, wenn irgendwie Privatleute... Es gibt auch Privatleute, die einfach mal in eine Base Station hinschauen und sagen, hey, ich hab Flatride, mich kostet Traffic nichts und ich bestrahle mal so einen Platz. Und da können irgendwie alle Leute, die das wissen, Internet haben. Ist auch ganz lieb. Und es gibt da schon einige größere Plätze, wo man ganz gemütlich in der Sonne liegen kann und dann einfach mal Internet hat, auch legal von dem Betreiber der Base Station auch gewollt. Aber wie gesagt, suchen ist immer ein bisschen müßig und wenn es halt solche Netze sind, dann ist es halt nicht weiter bedenklich. Aber schön zu wissen, dass wenn man irgendwie unterwegs ist, dass man da auch überall Internet haben kann. Und deswegen ist es so mit dem Anekdoten erzählen, so man schneidet sich ein bisschen ins eigene Fleisch.
Einmal war vielleicht ganz lustig, da gab es halt so ein Consultingunternehmen, die haben ja eine Firewall und Security verkauft.
Das ist ja lustig, dass die das verkaufen.
Naja, die haben halt irgendwie gesagt, man braucht unbedingt eine Firewall, weil dann ist man ganz sicher geschützt gegen die Bösen im Internet.
Es war sehr lustig zu lesen auf deren Webseite über den offenen Waveland.
Wenn ihr mit uns über offenes Waveland oder überhaupt Waveland reden wollt und ich die Jingle-Maschine nicht falsch bedient hätte, dann würde euch jetzt eine Stimme sagen, wie die Nummer hier ist. Und zwar diese Stimme.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Waveland, falls ihr Fragen habt zu Waveland, falls ihr Anmerkungen habt zu Waveland, falls ihr wisst, wo im Sendegebiet irgendwo frisch nett Internet, und zwar für lau und draußen, weil ein Netz offen ist, rumsteht, dann ruft ihr an unter 033 177 97 110 und sagt es uns. Wir sagen die ganze Zeit, wir reden über Wavelength Security und tun's gar nicht. Reden wir doch bitte mal über Sicherheit. Also, Web gibt's? WEP.
Genau. 40-Bit-Standard. Wurde damals irgendwie so beschlossen von USA, wegen den ganzen Exportbeschränkungen, was harte Kryptographie angeht. Es gibt noch eine sogenannte 128-Bit-Version. Das sind allerdings nur 104-Bit. Na ja, sicher ist beides nicht, habe ich ja nur schon mal gesagt.
Aber du hast mir aber auch gesagt, dass wenn ich das auf Windows habe, dann muss ich einfach nur Sicherheit anklicken.
Das Protokoll selber halt halt seine Schwachstellen. Also schon alleine dieser Algorithmus. Also es gibt, das wird ja so verschlüsselt, man hat da halt einen Key, den jeder wissen muss. Der Access Point braucht den und der Client, also die Station braucht den. Und so ein Paket, was jetzt über diesen Link verschickt wird, wird mit einem, also da wird erst ein Initialisierungsvektor gebildet, der ist immer 24-Bit lang bei beiden Versionen, bei dem 40-Bit und bei der 128-Bit Version. Dann wird über RC4 daraus ein Keystream gebildet und dieser Keystream wird mit der Nachricht, die verschlüsselt werden soll, gxodert und verschickt.
Meine Herren, direkt nähern sie mir das mal.
Also xodern ist so eine mathematische Operation, da werden zwei Bits genommen, zwei Zustände, eins oder null und wenn sie nicht gleich sind, dann wird es eins gesetzt. Ganz einfach. Und das ist reversibel, weil wenn man zweimal ein Bit xor mit demselben Wert, dann guckt wieder das alte raus. Also ist die Verschlüsselung ziemlich cool, man kann eine Zufallsreihe errechnen, die der andere auch errechnen kann. Damit xodern jedes einzelne Bit und schickt es rüber auf der anderen Seite xodern, dass es wieder mit demselben Streamliner errechnet hat und man dann den Klartext.
Das habe ich zumindest ansatzweise kapiert.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass dieser Initialisierungsweck da 24 Bit lang ist und bei jedem Päckchen um einen zu incrementieren wird. Das heißt, man hat eine begrenzte Anzahl von Werten, die man da für diesen Keystream benutzen kann. Der wiederholt sich auch mal und wenn sich der wiederholt, dann kann man da... Also gut, dazu muss ich sagen, wenn diese Nachricht verschlüsselt wurde, wird dieser Initialisierungsvektor im Klartext zusammen mit der Nachricht über diesen Link geschickt. Das heißt, man kann quasi diesen Initialisierungsvektor sehen, der ist nicht verschlüsselt. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie feststellt, der wurde jetzt zweimal benutzt, dann könnte man zum Beispiel diese beiden verschlüsselten Nachricht wieder miteinander XORen und hätte damit irgendwie ein XOR von den beiden Plain Text, also den beiden unverschlüsselten Nachrichten. Wenn man ungefähr weiß, was da drinstehen könnte in diesem Plain Text, dann kann man das auch leicht rausfinden. Und so zumindest dieses Paket entschlüsseln. Und wenn man da so ein paar Informationen gesammelt hat, wie oft, also man kann sich richtige Wörterbücher anlegen mit diesen Key Streams, die wiederholen sich auch. Dann kann man irgendwann halt auch den gesamten Datenverkehr damit lesen. Und auch, also das geht halt auch so weit, dass man da Daten einspeisen kann, manipulieren kann. Das ist dann eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
Und das betrifft dann mich, der ich mir das zu Hause hinstelle, weil ich in meinem Schlafzimmer drahtloses Internet auch haben will.
Ja und du fühlst dich wahrscheinlich auch noch sicher, weil du eine tolle Firewall hast und irgendwie diese WEP-Verschlüsselung angeschaltet hast.
Und dann steht unten wieder jemand im Auto und macht Klick auf dein Skript und dann ist deine Web-Encrop schon total verhindert.
Das ist jetzt übrigens die Stimme von Krüx, der die ganze Zeit die Musik hier macht.
Multifunktionskrüx.
Multifunktionskrüx. Okay, gut, ich geh jetzt in den Laden, ich kauf mir diesen Access-Point, ich kauf mir eine Karte. Ich klick auf Sicherheit und dann kommt ihr Arschgeigen vorbei und schießt mich auf den Mond.
Genau, keine Sicherheit.
Gut, aber wie kann ich denn die Illusion von Sicherheit irgendwie erhöhen?
Na ja, da kommen wir dann nachher noch auf IPsec zu sprechen.
Da können wir doch einfach jetzt mal auf IPsec zu sprechen. Ach du wolltest demonstrieren?
Na ja, nicht demonstrieren, ich wollte jetzt einfach mal sagen, wie hoch die Chancen sind, dass sich so ein Initialisierungsvektor wiederholt. Also der wird bei den meisten Karten immer auf Null gesetzt, wenn zum Beispiel die Karte resettet wird. Wenn da mehrere Laptops mit diesen Karten unterwegs sind, dann ist da eh die Chance schon ziemlich groß, dass sich dieser Key einfach mal wiederholt.
Die Karte resetten ist dann aber auch tatsächlich ein Reset an der Karte durchfunden? Oder ist es Ausschalten, Einschalten?
Ausschalten, Einschalten, Rausziehen, Einstecken.
Also je mehr Traffic einfach über dieses Wavelang geht, desto schneller hat man auch diese Daten zusammen.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass so ein Access Point die ganze Zeit mit LFM-Bit sendet oder empfängt, also Datenverkehr hat von LFM-Bit pro Sekunde und die Pakete im Durchschnitt maximal 1500 Byte groß sind, dann kommt man darauf, dass innerhalb von 18.000 Sekunden, also 5 Stunden, dass sich da die Keys schon mal wiederholen. Und da fängt das dann an interessant zu werden.
Und das ist quasi nichts?
Naja, es ist nichts, nichts. Aber in so einem Laptop kann man auch in sein Auto stellen, 5 Stunden Kaffee trinken gehen, dann hebelig wieder zurückkommen und gucken, was passiert ist.
Hebelig vor allen Dingen. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer. Nehmen wir den noch an und danach reden wir über IPSEC, oder?
Ich hätt's in der Leitung.
Tut mir leid.
Ist doch wunderbar, so ein spannendes Thema. Ein bisschen schwer nachzuvollziehen, so viel denke ich.
Ja, ich bemühe mich auch, aber es ist schwierig. XOR meinst du jetzt, ja? Meinst du XOR, ja?
Ah nee, XOR ist halt trivial eigentlich.
Das ist trivial, ja? Ist das.
Es geht darum, um zwei Fragen. Erstmal, wie richtet ihr euch gemütlich ein? Thema eins, Stromversorgung ist das Problem. Nach wie vor mit Notebooks, diverse Arten. Wahrscheinlich ziehen die Karten auch ganz gut Strom, denke ich mal.
Ja, außerdem, ich meine, wenn man im Auto ist, kann man auch genügend Platz, noch eine USB mitzunehmen.
Und was? Unterbrechungsvolle Stromversorgung.
Ach so, ihr habt einfach USB nicht verstanden.
Weil ihr es könnt halt.
Ja, die Dinge hab ich auch billig auf dem Flohmarkt.
Man nicht Lärm oder so? Ach so, das sind dicke Bleiakkus oder so. Das andere Ding ist Rechtsgrundlage. Ich meine, habt ihr mal Stress bekommen? Oder, ich meine, Daimler und so, die haben bestimmt auch eine ganz gute Batterie, eine Überwachungsanlage, sprich zu Kameras. Und auch so Leute in lustigen Uniformen, die ab und zu rumschleichen.
Na die mit der Uniform, die werden bestimmt nicht aufmerksam.
Also einmal haben wir einen Wachschützer gehabt, der ein bisschen böse guckte und irgendwie rauskam, aber das war glaube ich nur, weil wir total verpeilt aus waren. Es war 5 Uhr morgens oder so.
Ich kann euch ja eigentlich nicht verbieten, euch einzulingen, solange nichts manipuliert wird.
Naja, also die Rechtsgrundlage ist eher schwammig. Also es ist schon so, dass halt irgendwie Ausspielen von Daten und Manipulieren von Daten, also Manipulieren von Daten machen wir definitiv nie. Aber Ausspielen von Daten kann man tatsächlich, ja, so und so sehen. Also die Definition ist ja eigentlich, dass man irgendwie eine wesentliche Schranke überwinden muss, um tatsächlich irgendwie diese Straftat zu begehen. Und naja, es würde dann theoretisch ein Richter obliegen, irgendwie zu urteilen, ob irgendwie das Reinstecken einer Wechselkarte an ein Laptop und hin anzuschalten, irgendwie das Überwinden einer wesentlichen Schranke ist.
Das Problem ist, es ist halt sehr mutfüllig. Es erscheint schon sehr mutfüllig, wenn ihr halt da mit einer USB anreidet.
Na gut, aber tatsächlich ist es so, das einfachste ist halt... Ja gut, aber es ist tatsächlich nicht Überwinden einer wesentlichen Schranke.
Nee, nee, physisch nicht, das ist Problem, es ist so Partikmenwechsel.
Naja, nee, also auch tatsächlich, ich muss kein Passwort... ich muss kein Passwort... Also insofern, klar, wir sehen es halt so, wir passen schon auf, was wir da tun. Und reden halt in jedem Fall hinterher mit den Leuten, also wenn es halt irgendwie tatsächlich besonders krass ist. Weil diese Weltkrankgeschichte ist halt einfach so, dass es so viele sind, dass man gar nicht mit allen reden kann. Und deswegen versuchen wir halt tatsächlich auch über die Medien da ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit zu erreichen.
Mein Eindruck ist so ein bisschen, in Zukunft wird es so abgehen, dass sich wirklich nur Leute, die Kohle haben, Sicherheit leisten können.
Nee, also es ist tatsächlich einfach nur eine Frage von Zeit und Motivation. Also in der Regel haben die Leute, die Kohle haben, die schlecht ist, Sicherheit.
Du brauchst einfach wahnsinnig viel Zeit, um die ganze Problematik einzuordnen. Ich meine, die meisten Leute sind schon überfordert, wenn sie sagen, was, HTTP? Ist das gleiche wie irgendwie WDW, Web? Das Problem ist, der Horizont des Verstehens wird immer enger. Weil einfach die ganzen Techniken expandieren ohne Ende. Ich meine, ich bin jeden Tag bestimmt zwei Stunden beschäftigt, irgendwie auf O'Reilly, Internet und sonst da irgendwie so auf dem Laufen zu bleiben. Und hey, das ist einfach explodiert.
Ja, na die ganze Thematik ist schon recht komplex. Security ist immer komplex. Es wird einfach nicht dazu kommen, dass man sich hinsetzt und wie gesagt IP-Sicherheit oder so anklickt und es geht. Funktioniert einfach nicht, da muss einfach Aufwand betrieben werden.
Es sollte vielleicht auch ein bisschen subventioniert sein, in der Strafvergünstigung, vielleicht in irgendeiner Weise, weil...
Wieso subventioniert werden?
Weil es propagiert wird, wenn es halt länger bittet, weil in Europa ist ja, da gab es schon so viele Wörter. Also für PGP gab es doch schon viele Sprecher vom, weiß nicht...
Du meinst, du willst die Leute dazu zwingen, dass sie ihre Netze sich anbauen?
Ja, einfach einfach auf Aufmerksam machen, Leute.
Ja, natürlich, das tun wir ja eigentlich auch mit diesen Wörtern, wenn ich mich mache, wir machen darauf Aufmerksam.
In einem Sternenartikel, wo eure AIPAC-Aktion oder was ist, war, dass da angeblich halt ein paar Leute mit AIPACs so rumgestrohlen haben, als wenn es schwindelnd ist, dass sie wirklich mit AIPACs in einer Wastelandkarte unterwegs waren und...
Klar, ich meine, die Dinger passen in die Jackentasche, also...
Ich warte auf den Palm-Pilot, aber das ist wahrscheinlich schnell genug für solche Sachen. Ja, das wär's eigentlich auch schon.
Dann danken wir für deinen Anruf.
Und danke für die schöne Musik, war echt gut.
Ja, keine Ursache. Und danke, dass du gesagt hast, dass die Dinge, die ich nicht weiß, trivial sind.
Nicht halt wirklich der Schriftführungsalgorithmus, da schnall ich ab. Ich meine nur x an sich.
Wieder ans Kreuz genagelt. Was fehlt?
Ja, ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja festgestellt, dass Web eigentlich auch... Oll ist. Ja, also was gibt's denn für einen Schutz? Also grundsätzlich sollte man ja alles, was man so im Netz macht, verschlüsseln. Das heißt, das fängt irgendwie bei der E-Mail an. Das ist einfach nicht selbstverständlich, dass die Leute den ganzen Krampel verschlüsseln. Man sollte SSL-Rapper einsetzen, also alles, was man... also meinetwegen Pop3 kann man auch über SSL machen oder HTTP, wie auch immer. Und die sicherste Variante ist zum Beispiel IPsec. Das heißt, man stellt seine Base Station, seinen Access Point irgendwo in eine geschützte Zone. Meinetwegen jetzt im Firmenetzwerk, da hat man halt verschiedene Zonen, die mit Firewalls unterschiedlich abgesichert sind. Und baut sich dann quasi über den Laptop, über diesen Access Point ins interne Netz, also so ein VPN-Virtual-Private-Network.
Genau.
Virtual-Private-Network. Ja, und das ganze Teil halt verschlüsselt mit IPSEC. Und das ist so gesehen ziemlich sicher. Und vielleicht kann uns da der Krügs einfach was erzählen.
Ja, wo gerade der Anrufer sagte, es werden sich nur die Leute sicher leisten können, die genug Geld haben. Also IPSEC ist ja nun inzwischen auch schon auf diesen, ganz besonders auf den freien Betriebssystemen, also Linux und die ganzen BSD-Derivate vorhanden. Und Windows 2000 hat das auch gleich mit drinne. Also praktisch hat jeder, der sich einen Rechner kauft, mit Windows 2000 drauf, hat sofort IPSEC drauf. Aber, es ist eben nicht nur IP-Sicherheit anklicken. Das funktioniert immer wieder eben nicht. Man muss Tunnel konfigurieren, man muss Routing machen, man muss die Keys einstellen, etc. Es ist nicht ganz einfach, man muss sich auf jeden Fall reinfuchsen, aber wenn man es mal hingekriegt hat, kann man relativ...
Das Reinfuchsen würde dann ja auch bedingen, dass ich Zeit habe, mich reinzufuchsen, und das heißt, dass ich Geld haben muss.
Das hast du aber bei der E-Mail eben auch. Wenn du die PGP verschließen willst, dann ist es auch nicht einfach nur klicken, sondern du musst dich schon ein bisschen damit auseinandersetzen.
Ich weiß nicht, also es gibt es zum Klicken.
Ja, es gibt es schon zum Klicken, aber man muss sich trotzdem mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen. Das ist nicht standardmäßig an.
Das ist richtig. Also wenn der Aufwand des Auseinandersetzens dann bei IPsec ist, dann wär's ja okay, dann wär's ja leiser.
Ja, na, er ist ein Ende größer, sagen wir mal. Aber dafür ist dann auch echt sicher. Es geht halt einfach daran aus, dass nicht nur verschiedene Connections verschließt werden, sondern eine gesamte Connection verschließt wird. Alle Daten, die aus diesem Notebook dann rausgehen würden, die dann an diesen IPsec-Router gehen, sind verschlüsselt, geschieht in zwei Phasen. Einmal Phase 1. Da wird halt der Key ausgehandelt. Und wie jetzt der Tunnel aufgebürt wird. Und welche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen benutzt werden. Und so. Da kann man dann auch wählen. Das Schöne ist nämlich, dass da zwischen verschiedenen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen gewählt werden kann. Also Triple Desk Desk. Rehandel gibt es jetzt noch. Und was es da noch nicht alles gibt. Hash Funktionen, SHA-1, MD5. Also die Crypto, die da wirklich drin steckt, die ist schon ganz ordentlich. Man kann da richtig sicher mit machen. Und eben auch mit Windows. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Mittel fehlen.
Gibt es da irgendwie noch die passende Webseite dazu? Also wo ich das dann auch für so Leute wie mich schön zum Nachlesen und so?
Na ja, du musst dir erstmal so eine Route hinstellen und die musst du dann schon unter einem freien Unix-Derivat irgendwie benutzen. Also müsstest du da schon mal Aufwand treiben. Man könnte das Ganze allerdings auch in so Setupboxen dir hinstellen, mehr oder weniger. Wenn das die Firmen machen. Ich verstehe immer nicht, warum diese Base Station Hersteller nicht einfach da nach APSEC mehr draufgeknallt haben. Das hätten sie ruhig noch tun können. Da hätten sie zwar irgendwie mehr Prozessorleistung gebraucht, weil es eben Krypto ist. Aber das hätten sie ruhig mal tun sollen. Dann wärs richtig cool gewesen. Dann wäre halt im Konfig klicken und richtig sicher haben. So will man das nämlich genau haben.
Am falschen Ende gespart.
Ist es abzusehen, dass sie das irgendwann doch noch mal machen?
Mit der Hardware, die diese Moment da drinne haben, schaffen sie das garantiert nicht. Ob sie es machen, naja, ist doch eine Frage. Weiß ich nicht.
Es gibt auch keine Meldungen, dass einer gesagt hat, wir machen IPsec, sobald die Prozessoren billiger sind?
Billig sind die Prozessoren. Das kann man in einen Kropotestor reinwerfen, der speziell für die Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen ausgelegt ist. Der verbraucht dann auch nicht wirklich.
Ich glaube, das Ziel war jetzt erstmal, bei den Base stations, die sie zu Hause bringen, erstmal eine Marktdurchdrehung für die zu erreichen.
Die haben einfach rausgeworfen.
Guck dir an, was in der Apple Base station drin ist. Das ist ein 486 oder ein Pensium reinzustecken, hätte den doppelt so teuer gemacht.
Nein, ein Pensium wirst du ja eben genau nicht reinwerfen, sondern du wirst einen ordentlichen Krypto Prozess machen.
Na ja, okay, die sind auch nicht so richtig doll billig.
Ja, die sind nicht billig, aber naja.
Also wie gesagt, ich vermute mal, die wollten einfach mal unter bestimmten Preismarken bleiben und wird deswegen nicht gemacht, weil wer braucht das?
Außerdem können sie jetzt nochmal verkaufen.
Genau, nächste Welle.
Jetzt, wo wir die Leute verunsichert haben. So, jetzt, wo wir die Leute verunsichert haben, jetzt können sie noch mehr verkaufen. Ich huge nicht an, so nicht beendete. Dann gehen wir jetzt nach Hause, oder?
Oder in die Richtung.
Bisschen Musik kommt eh noch. Wir hören jetzt noch elektronische Musik und danach habe ich noch einen Chill-Out Titel rausgesucht. Das war's, das war Chaosradio 61 auf Fritz. Waveline Security bzw. hauptsächlich die Anekdotensammlung um unsichere Wavelinennetze haben wir gehört. Ich hoffe, der eine oder andere merkt sich, dass fremde Daten nicht ausspielen werden dürfen. Artig bleiben. Genau, artig bleiben, bleibt sauber. Was behalten wir übrig am Ende der Sendung? Nee, das war was anderes. Gute Nacht, ja, gute Nacht und danke der SeeWeit Jungs. Das nächste Chaosradio übrigens am letzten Mittwoch, im nächsten Monat, was dann quasi der Juni wäre. Ich weiß nicht, was das Datum ist, ich glaube 26.
oder sowas.
Tschö und Tschau.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB. Produziert in Babelsberg.